bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
donc l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la motion de censure
déposée en application d'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution par Monsieur
André chassaine madame Mathilde panot
monsieur Boris Vallot madame Cyrielle
châtelain et 143 membres de l'Assemblée
la première ministre ayant engagé la
responsabilité du Gouvernement sur
l'adoption en lecture définitive du
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 donc
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas sans su
pour le groupe coach démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame la présidence mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
49.39.3 et 10 de der quelle tristesse
quelle désolation de voir ainsi
l'Assemblée nationale piétiné humilié
sauf qu'ici on ne joue pas à la belette
belote mesdames et messieurs les
ministres et si pour cette séquence
budgétaire nous sommes au bout d'un
exercice qui aura abîmé la démocratie je
veux rappeler qu'il est indécent de
vouloir inverser la charge de la preuve
il peut exister des recours à l'article
49-3 de notre Constitution sans dépôt de
motion de censure mais il n'existe pas
de motion censure 149,3 c'est donc bien
votre refus de débattre qui conduit au
dépôt de cette motion que j'ai l'honneur
de défendre au nom de tous les groupes
de la gauche et des écologistes elle est
finupes écologiste nupes socialiste GDR
nupes votre lecture de l'article 49-3 de
notre texte fondamental est tout de même
sing dans toute notre histoire l'usage
voulait que les discussions aillent au
terme des textes ou quasiment l'usage
voulait que les amendements voter en
séance soient pour la plupart et
notamment les plus emblématiques repris
dans le texte final sur lequel le
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
vous avez balayé ces usages engoncé à la
fois dans votre arrogance et dans le
refus d'admettre une fois pour toutes
que le président Macron n'a pas été
choisi pour son programme par des
millions de ces électeurs lors du
deuxième tour du scrutin présidentiel je
fais partie de ces millions de Français
qui ont toujours combattu combattent et
combattront cette extrême droite qui
porte la division la haine de l'autre et
le replie nationaliste nous combattons
cette extrême droite d'autant plus que
les agressions racistes les actes
ultra-violents les appellent à la haine
ressurgissent dans notre pays des
groupes identitaires n'hésitent plus à
s'afficher des groupuscules dissous en
sommeil se reforment il ne faudra pas
trembler pour faire cesser les
agissements de cet extrême droite qui
attaquent les fondements même de la
République face à cela les députés
communiste et ultramarins du groupe de
la Gauche démocrate et républicaine mais
au-delà tous les députés de gauche et
écologistes ne failliront pas comme ils
n'ont jamais failli pourtant il est
nécessaire de s'interroger sur le
terreau qui fait prospérer cette extrême
droite car il faut briser la montée en
France comme dans l'Europe entière de
ces idées nausées à bondes bien sûr que
c'est l'affaire de tous les républicains
de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent continuer le combat des lumières
celui du renversement de l'Ancien Régime
celui de 1848 de la Commune de Paris du
Front populaire du Conseil National de
la Résistance c'est le moment de
l'histoire qui ont embrassé notre devise
républicaine
notre responsabilité collective est donc
immense chacune et chacun à sa place
votre responsabilité madame la Première
ministre que je salue est encore plus
grande car vous dirigez notre pays dans
ces moments de risque de basculement
vers des heures sombres or faire vivre
la République et le Parlement c'est
l'inverse de la brutalité dont vous avez
fait preuve lors de ce débat budgétaire
l'humilité et la composition de notre
assemblée décidez par nos concitoyens
auraient dû vous éviter de dériver de
l'exercice de communication des
dialogues de Bercy vers la rafale de
49.3 madame la Première ministre
pourquoi avez-vous si peur du débat en
première partie de ce projet de loi de
finances nous n'avons étudié que 5
articles le couperait tant tombé
opportunément avant le débat sur la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises qui
privera le budget de l'État de plus de 8
milliards d'euros en deux ans et qui a
moins de risques considérablement le
lien entre activités économique et
bassin de vie expliquer qu'il s'agit là
d'un dispositif indispensable pour la
relocalisation industrielle est une
farce la valeur ajoutée créée au global
c'est plus de 2000 milliards d'euros la
CVAE c'est donc l'équivalent de 0,4 % de
ce nombre la constance de votre credo
idéologique pour ressusciter un brin
d'admiration si cela ne confinait pas à
placer le pays en grande fragilité le
partage de cette valeur ajoutée qui est
au fond l'indicateur le plus fiable pour
connaître la visée politique et la
visite d'une politique économique est de
plus en plus défavorable au travail il
n'est qu'à voir par exemple le
creusement des rémunérations entre
salariés dirigeants au sein des
entreprises du CAC 40 le ratio d'équité
celui qui compare ses rémunérations
montre une dérive patente en 2014 le
dirigeant le mieux payé touché en
moyenne 75 fois la rémunération moyenne
des salariés
en 2018 ce ratio est passé à 86 et en
2021 à 109 la crise n'est pas la même
pour tout le monde nous ne confondrons
pas ces dirigeants et ses entreprises
avec le monde des très petites
entreprises et des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont toujours sur le fil
du rasoir étranglé par des charges
d'énergie complètement délirante les
augmentations de l'énergie pour tous les
foyers pour toutes les entreprises pour
toutes les collectivités provoqueront la
cristallisation des rancœurs c'est
surtout la marque de l'impérici du
gouvernement et de cette Europe libérale
qui détruit des vies et épuisent la
planète le bouclier tarifaire
d'aujourd'hui ce sont les profits total
de demain voilà le corollaire de vos
choix en matière d'énergie en fait c'est
l'extrême ponction que vous administrez
à tous les ménages les entreprises les
collectivités locales sur lesquelles je
souhaite m'arrêter
de débat sur les collectivités locales
vous ne vouliez point conscient que la
trajectoire que vous proposez est
injuste
inefficace et inéquitable ainsi
l'amortisseur énergie est complètement
contre intuitif puisqu'il peut pousser à
consommer plus d'énergie pour entrer
dans le champ du remboursement
vous feriez bien également de ne pas
ignorer les difficultés liées aux autres
augmentations des biens des services et
de la rémunération des personnels car
c'est l'autofinancement des
collectivités locales que vous mettez en
péril et derrière ce sont des milliards
d'euros d'investissement public qui
manqueront au pays pour répondre aux
défis climatiques au défi économiques au
défi social le défi social c'est d'abord
à celui-ci que nous aurions dû répondre
dans les territoires d'outre-mer quelle
occasion manquée et quelle faute
politique alors que de tous les bandes
de notre hémicycle étaient montés
l'exigence d'un plan ambitieux de
rattrapage des dispositifs qui tendaient
à faire respecter un peu plus l'égalité
cette valeur cardinale de notre
République vous avez ignoré l'ampleur de
ces exigences l'ampleur des besoins en
matière de santé de sécurité d'éducation
tout simplement d'une présence accrue de
l'État au contraire avec le texte que
vous avez fait adopter sans vote de
nouveaux mauvais coups sont à l'ordre du
jour ah le fameux compte personnel de
formation qui désormais pourrait être
activé avec une participation du salarié
pas mal de 49-3 pour faire passer
l'écouteurs du et puis comment accepter
qu'il n'y ait eu aucun débat sur le
logement alors que plus de 20% de nos
concitoyens ne peuvent se chauffer
correctement pas plus de débats sur
l'éducation la culture ce qui fait que
l'homme est autre chose qu'un accident
de l'univers comme disait Malraux madame
la Première ministre nous savons bien
que tout un chacun doit amener sa pierre
les députés communistes et les outre-mer
qui forment le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine le font avec
leurs conviction leur soif de débat
persuadé que du débat public et de la
contradiction se dessine les chemins de
l'avenir nous continuerons de débattre
de porter les choix d'un modèle
alternatif celui qui instaure une
fiscalité plus juste plus progressive
plus directe un modèle qui fait des
services publics la pierre angulaire de
la reconquête républicaine en
s'attaquant à la rente et à la commune à
l'accumulation de fortune indécentes
certes dans la configuration de
l'Assemblée issue des élections
législatives qui n'ont pas accordé une
majorité au Président il n'est pas
incongru que le gouvernement est recours
au 49-3 pour les lois de finances mais
ceux qui l'est c'est de ne pas respecter
le travail qui a été effectué comment
avez-vous pu passer par perte et profits
la taxation sur les super dividendes
adoptait une écrase entre majorité
comment avez-vous pu rayé d'un trade
plume l'avancée pour tous les résidents
en EHPAD avec la transformation au
crédit d'impôt du dispositif de
déduction fiscale actuelle voilà
illustré la dichotomie entre le discours
et les actes entre votre soi-disant
volonté de construction et l'arrogance
de vos dogmes qui transpirent dans les
textes définitifs ce feu dans Madame la
première ministre vous concourrez à
rendre le pays encore plus divisé et
tendu qu'il ne l'est déjà nos
compatriotes souffrent de l'inflation
nos compatriotes souffrent de votre
inaction pour faire reculer les déserts
médicaux pour assurer un accès aux soins
partout nos compatriotes dans une très
grande majorité et d'abord les actifs ne
veulent pas de la contre-réforme des
retraites que vous vous apprêtez à
déposer brutalement et cyliquement
écoutez-les alors que sur notre
continent européen la guerre ferrages
que les règles libérales européennes qui
nous assaillent sont le carburant des
inégalités que les décisions d'une
petite caste font si mal à la planète
vous poursuivez bardez de certitudes et
si parfois vous pouviez avoir tort cela
vous traverse vous traversent-ils
l'esprit pour redonner à notre pays à
notre peuple en lien avec les peuples du
monde la seule chose qui vaille celle
qui faisait dire à Paul Eluard il ne
faut pas de tout pour faire un monde il
faut du bonheur et rien d'autre madame
la Première ministre c'est parce que
nous voulons que vous cessiez de
brutaliser non pas seulement le
Parlement mais nos concitoyens que nous
voterons cette dernière motion de
censure de la législature je l'espère
qu'elle sera la dernière et qu'elle le
restera merci à tous
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Nadia est pour le
groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement chers
plus de 150 heures de débats entre la
Commission et l'hémicycle pour le PLF
voilà la matérialité du débat
démocratique ces dernières semaines au
sein des 300 blé et pourtant nous voilà
contraint encore une fois de faire face
à l'obstacle du blocage pour que notre
pays se dotent d'un budget en bonne et
due forme avant la fin de l'année
chacune des oppositions ici présente a
clairement énoncé affirmé et assumer son
refus de voter le projet de loi de
Finances du gouvernement et ce quel
qu'il soit
aurait-il fallu dans ce cas que le
gouvernement laisse notre pays sans
budget pour fonctionner aurait-il fallu
que le gouvernement laisse les Français
sans protection heureusement que le
génie de la Constitution de la Cinquième
République a anticiper ses oppositions
de posture en permettant cet outil du
49-3 qui permet de transcender les
blocages et non de contourner les
oppositions
dixième 49,3 dites-vous et bien dixième
motion de censure nous vous répondons
certes avec le
certes avec le succès que nous
connaissons pour les 9 précédentes mais
avouez tout de même que la Constitution
est plutôt bien faite le gouvernement
prend ses responsabilités sur l'adoption
d'un texte et le pouvoir législatif
dispose de moyens pour lui répondre donc
en réalité c'est un partout la balle au
centre pour en revenir au projet de loi
de finances qui est à l'origine de la
discussion de ce jour notre groupe
parlementaire Renaissance tient à
rappeler qu'en Commission dans
l'hémicycle et dans les nombreux
anti-chambres d'échanges parlementaires
des compromis ont été tentés des
propositions d'amendement étudiées avec
rigueur des tentatives des discussions
étaient proposées pour produire un texte
enrichi étoffé et intelligemment
co-construit
mais hélas le dogme a rapidement figé
les bonnes volontés dans leurs élans à
une fin de non-recevoir de principes a
été opposé à toute velléité d'accord
l'obsession du rejet telle est la forme
de nos débats durant cette période
budgétaire la forme c'est le fond qui
remonte à la surface disait Victor Hugo
c'est bien cela dont il s'agit le rejet
préalable et systématique de ces textes
budgétaires ne révélait que la volonté
de bloquer le pays une obsession du
désordre une soif de révolution que
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
brandissent comme une chimère sous les
yeux des Français
les Français ne sont pas dupe ils
comprennent bien que ces 49-3 successifs
et rappelons-le comme la très justement
rappeler le rapporteur général qu'il ne
s'agit en réalité qu'un seul 49-3 car il
ne s'agit que d'un seul exercice
budgétaire le budget et le financement
de la sécurité sociale et bien ce 49-3
n'est que la réponse à votre entêtement
de ne pas donner une seule chance au
succès du débat parlementaire et
l'émotion de rejet successives en sont
la parfaite illustration les Français
ont bien noté cet étrange schizophrénie
parlementaire ces dernières semaines qui
consistent à présenter d'émotions de
rejet préalable par lesquelles les
oppositions rejettent d'emblée des
textes fondamentaux pour nos finances
publiques et pour le financement de la
sécurité sociale en tâchant ainsi
systématiquement le débat d'une mauvaise
volonté
alors nous aimerions que vous répondiez
à ces questions comment voulez-vous
enrichir un texte que vous rejetez
d'emblée comment voulez-vous faire
avancer un projet de société si vous le
condamnez d'avance
l'ironie de la chose et que lorsque le
gouvernement se trouve face à cette
situation de rejet préalable et donc
contraint de faire adopter les textes
afin que le pays continue de fonctionner
que nos fonctionnaires soient payés que
nos entreprises continuent de produire
que nos associations continuent
devraient que les Français soient
davantage protégés par l'inflation qui
frappe partout dans le monde
oui pour tout cela lorsque le
gouvernement choisi de faire aboutir les
textes budgétaires et transcendez ces
obstacles de circonstances qui font fit
de l'intérêt général nous assistons à
des cris d'orfray face aux 49-3
chers collègues chacune de vos émotions
de réagir préalable était en réalité une
invitation une demande express à
utiliser le 49-3 et à chaque fois la
première ministre y a répondu elle a
répondu à votre demande avec
responsabilité éclairvoyance la première
ministre vous a répondu en engageant la
responsabilité de son gouvernement avec
courage et ceux dans l'intérêt des
Français les Français vos électeurs en
particulier ont souhaité une assemblée
diversifiée pour stimuler le débat et
l'échange or vous n'avez donné aucune
chance à cette nouvelle dynamique vous
exigez un grand écart improbable un
grand écart impossible même quand les
parties d'opposition demandent même
quand c'est même partie d'opposition
demande à ouvrir les vannes de la dette
ou à l'augmentation des impôts et en
même temps ils appellent à la dépense du
déficit public
un grand écart exigé quand on sait
pertinemment que si nous penchons d'un
côté ou de l'autre cela heurtera les
engagements du Président de la
République pris devant les Français qui
l'ont élu et qui lui ont donné un groupe
majoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
cela vous déplaît peut-être mais c'est
la réalité politique d'aujourd'hui
quel que soit nos désaccords quel que
soit votre désapprobation quant à cette
disposition constitutionnelle qui
autorise le gouvernement à débloquer ce
type de situation il demeure que le
professeurs dans nos écoles notre police
nos fonctionnaires dans les hôpitaux nos
collectivités doivent toutes pouvoir
être opérationnel au 1er janvier tel est
le courage et la responsabilité dans la
décision de la première ministre et ce
malgré la frustration que cela engendre
pour nous tous car nous savons tous nous
avons tous ici à cœur le débat
parlementaire
monsieur le Président Coquerel vous
dites qu'on ne peut pas conditionner le
débat parlementaire au vote du projet de
loi
et bien si quand il s'agit du budget de
la France car il conditionne le
fonctionnement de son état de ses
administrations des collectivités des
fonctionnaires et bien nous devons
évidemment voter ce projet de loi vous
dites aussi que si nous avions pris
certaines de vos propositions et celles
des oppositions compromettant au passage
le projet de loi du gouvernement nous
aurions pu laisser la chance au projet
d'aboutir
or c'est tout le pays que vous tentez de
faire échouer à l'aune de cette
opposition de principe vous nous semez
ensuite de former des compromis sur le
PLF même lorsque cela dans va dans votre
sens vous censurer vous rejetez Vous
vous opposez sans jamais construire
alors sachez que le groupe Renaissance
ne souhaite pas participer à cette
mascarade à cette hypocrisie qui
consiste à laisser du temps à un débat
au débat un texte qui n'aboutira pas et
vous vous dites défenseur de l'intérêt
général je n'y vois elascaveuglement et
caricature et cela n'est pas de nature à
redonner confiance en la politique
le blocage n'a jamais été un moyen de
noble politique contraindre le
gouvernement à usé de l'action
constitutionnelle du 49.3 pour sécuriser
un budget pour le pays en ces temps de
crise n'est pas un combat politique
c'est une hérésie de gouvernance le
mandat qui nous a été confié
collectivement et d'assurer une gestion
responsable du pays en faveur de
l'action et non pas en faveur du blocage
ou de l'inertie
ceci chers collègues aider les terres
dans un contexte de crise la crise que
nous connaissons ceci constitue aussi le
terreau de tous les populismes de la
démagogie et de la décrédibilisation de
notre travail politique certains dans
cet assemblée nous le savons
œuvre sans relâche à cultiver ce terreau
et bien vous nous trouverez sur votre
passage la majorité présidentielle
dressera un mur en béton armé pour
protéger les Français de toute tendance
populiste
certains veulent tout fermer aucune
dépense et tant pis pour les plus
fragiles d'autres veulent tout ouvrir
sans aucune rigueur et tant pis pour la
dette qu'on laisse à nos enfants et que
dire de ceux qui veulent que la France
soit une île coupée du monde qui vit
replier sur elle-même niant ainsi les
enjeux de la mondialisation
là où les uns et les autres veulent nous
enfermer nous répondons libération des
énergies productives et investissements
pour l'avenir protection de nos
concitoyens et préservation de notre
unité nationale
hélas vos propositions chers collègues
ne répondent aucunement à cette ambition
chers collègues il est utile de rappeler
les fondamentaux et le sens de notre
action ici et maintenant nous sommes
dans une crise énergétique sanitaire
international parfois même une crise de
sens pour nos concitoyens
particulièrement pour notre jeunesse le
gouvernement est notre majorité ont pris
pleinement la mesure des enjeux et nous
avons choisi sans trembler de
transcender les postures en ayant qu'une
seule et unique boussole l'intérêt des
Français
l'inflation inédite depuis 40 ans et la
guerre aux portes de l'Europe aurait dû
inciter l'ensemble des forces politiques
à se mobiliser pour sécuriser le budget
pour notre pays ce budget est protecteur
plafonnement de la hausse de
l'électricité du gaz pour les Français
accompagnement exceptionnel des
collectivités territoriales avec la
hausse inédite de la DGF et la création
d'un filet de sécurité l'effort
budgétaire est formidable et inédit sur
l'éducation nationale sur la défense
nationale des enjeux si cruciaux
aujourd'hui
l'effort budgétaire et résolument
volontariste sur la police et la
gendarmerie sur notre justice sur
l'apprentissage sur la rénovation
thermique sur les sous-préfectures et
l'accès aux services publics sur
l'objectif du plein emploi qui est un
vecteur essentiel à la lutte contre la
pauvreté
sur des priorités qui impactent
directement la vie de nos concitoyens
enfin c'est un budget de rigueur qui
maîtrise la dépense publique en œuvre à
la baisse du déficit public à 5% pour
cette année 2023 afin d'être en mesure
d'atteindre les trois pourcents de
déficit en 2027 ce qui est une politique
de rigueur et non pas une politique
d'austérité et c'est cela qui constitue
un désaccord profond avec les
républicains il nous invite à une vraie
politique d'austérité en exigeant à ce
qu'on le ramène le déficit public à 3%
en 2026 un jour il faudra vraiment nous
dire
ce que nous devons sacrifier nos écoles
nos hôpitaux nos forces de police et nos
gendarmerie nos services publics notre
justice quoi nous attendons toujours
ce budget est très honorable il est né
dans la douleur de la crise
multidimensionnelle que connaît notre
pays doubler d'une forme d'aveuglement
de nos oppositions obnubilé par les
querelles politiciennes alors que le
moment doit être à l'unité et à la
co-construction
chers collègues nous clôturons ainsi un
cycle budgétaire bien triste pour le
débat parlementaire mais réjouissant
pour nos concitoyens qui grâce à cette
décision de la première ministre de
faire usage du 49-3 ne restera pas dans
l'incertitude et dans la peur de
l'avenir notre groupe Renaissance se
réjouit de cela en acceptant volontiers
le sacrifice du débat parlementaire
notre groupe Renaissance continuera de
soutenir sans relâche le projet du
président de la République madame la
Première ministre notre groupe
Renaissance soutiendra sans relâche
l'action de votre gouvernement avec
audace avec la responsabilité que nous
incompte le mandat qui nous a été
confiée par les Français et sans
compromission sur nos valeurs et sur
notre projet soyez assuré de notre
engagement à vos côtés notre majorité
est fière de vous avoir comme première
ministre
quand un autre actualité parlementaire
en ces temps s'y troublé par cette crise
multidimensionnelle qui frappe notre
pays l'histoire retiendra d'un côté le
cynisme du blocage au service du
populisme et de l'autre le courage
politique au service de l'intérêt des
Français je vous remercie
je vous remercie ma chère collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Lionel Tivoli
pour le rassemblement national
merci
bien madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les députés mes chers collègues le voilà
le dixième 49-3 puis une nouvelle motion
de censure
tout cela prête à sourire et relèverait
du comique de situation si la situation
que vous provoquez pour l'avenir de la
France n'était pas aussi dramatique
le 19 juin dernier les Français se sont
exprimés lors des élections législatives
et en faisant entrer au Palais Bourbon
89 députés du rassemblement national les
Français vous ont adressé un
avertissement sévère en exprimant leur
totale désaccord sur 5 années d'échec et
de mensonges de la première mandature du
président Macron
vous ne disposez désormais pas
l'Assemblée nationale d'une majorité
absolue n'en déplaise à votre courant
politique
pourtant vous persistez dans le déni
politique et vos décisions aléatoires et
improviser qui mettent la France dans
une situation dangereuse
mais les Français privés jusqu'à lors
d'une véritable représentation nationale
ce sont dotées de porte-parole de taille
ici à l'Assemblée nationale en faisant
entrer 89 députés du rassemblement
national
cette voie des Français portait jusque
dans l'hémicycle vous refusez de
l'entendre car elle vous dérange dans
votre conception étrange de l'exercice
démocratique qui consiste à priver les
Français du débat démocratique par le
jeu dangereux du 49-3 madame la Première
ministre pourquoi le peuple français
mérite-t-il autant de mépris de votre
part
madame la Première ministre ce jeudi
vous êtes venu pour la 10e fois en
l'espace de 6 mois
usé et abusé de l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution française
vous êtes venus dire aux Français que
vous ne souhaitiez pas prendre en compte
le signal qu'il vous ont adressé lors
des dernières élections législatives
mais les Français ne sont pas dupe du
fait que vous vous moquez tout
simplement de vous qui avez eu
l'outrecuidance de vous présenter devant
la représentation nationale pour lui
lancer à la face l'idée d'un refus de
débat comme une projection de votre
propre refus du débat
madame la Première ministre pourquoi
avez-vous si peur du débat démocratique
dans notre hémicycle pourtant les débats
ont été de haute tenus malgré les pièges
tendus par la nups et des dans ce la par
ceux qui ont le plus peur de perdre leur
mandat que de défendre les doléances du
peuple français combien d'amendements
jetés à la décharge public combien de
jeunes collaborateurs ont été vidés de
leur motivation profonde par
l'utilisation vampirique du 49-3 vous
pensez un seul instant madame la
Première ministre que l'obstruction par
le recours infini au 49.3 muselera
longtemps la voie du peuple français je
crois que vous commettez une erreur
majeure sans compter l'irrespect et le
mépris que vous exprimez au travers de
cela face à nos compatriotes français
et vous vous prêtez d'ailleurs à
réitérer l'expérience pour la réforme
des retraites le 10 janvier 2023
le dogmatisme de la macronie serait-il
synonyme d'injustice et de régression
j'ai entendu de la part d'un d'une
personne proche de vous qu'il s'agirait
d'un 49-3 qui ne coûterait rien c'est
dire combien le Parlement est devenu la
proie aux manœuvres politiciens pour
museler l'opposition et la parole des
Français car oui pour vous ça ne coûtera
rien mais pour les Français ça coûtera
très cher
alors même que nous sommes en urgence
énergétique alors même que nous sommes
en urgence sanitaire alors même que nous
subissons une spirale inflationniste et
la récession alors même que les
fractures sociales n'ont jamais été
aussi béantes alors même que l'éducation
nationale est attaquée par l'hydre
islamiste alors même que nos
institutions sont mises à mal par la
déferlante des migrants alors même que
la précarité s'aggrave et que des
millions de Français n'ont plus
d'alternatives et doivent choisir entre
se nourrir et se chauffer alors même que
les chiffres de notre commerce extérieur
n'ont jamais été aussi catastrophiques
alors même que l'endettement national
n'a jamais été aussi élevé en raison de
vos choix erratiques alors même que nos
entreprises n'ont jamais été autant en
péril économique devant le remboursement
de leur dette suite à la crise de la
covid 19 vous n'avez rien retenu de
l'histoire et vous allez représenter une
réforme des retraites dont personne ne
veut tant elle est unique
l'erreur est humaine persévérer et
diabolique
pour ce PLF je le disais vous avez
mobilisé l'ensemble des parlementaires
vous avez mobilisé l'ensemble des
collaborateurs l'ensemble des services
de l'Assemblée nationale des parles des
débats parlementaires des auditions pour
rien car vous saviez qu'au final vous
allez balayer cette présence et tout ce
travail dans revers de la même tout cela
relève du gâchis et de la grande
mascarade
est-ce donc cela madame la Première
ministre votre manière de gouverner les
parlementaires font et vous à l'image
d'un vilain garnement qui part un coup
de pied rageur détruit le château de
sable que notre avait construit avec
tant de patience et d'écoute du peuple
français
au lieu de venir nous imposer le recours
au 49.3 une dixième fois vous auriez pu
écouter vos oppositions sur ce PLF vous
auriez pu démontrer lorsque vous dites
chercher le compromis que vous pouviez
transformer vos paroles en acte
au lieu de sortir grandi de cela vous
n'avez fait que démontrer votre
autoritarisme politique pourquoi
avez-vous refusé la taxation des super
dividendes des grandes entreprises
pourquoi avez-vous refusé le crédit
d'impôt en faveur des personnes en EHPAD
pourquoi avez-vous refusé le
rétablissement de l'exit tax contre
l'évasion fiscale pourquoi avez-vous
refusé la baisse de la TVA sur les
produits énergétiques
alors que la guerre grande anneau
frontières passoire la situation de la
France est trop grave pour ne pas
écouter la voix de l'opposition qui
aurait donné à notre pays un sentiment
d'union nationale
vous devez gouverner pour le peuple
français et pas contre le peuple
français
sous le premier gouvernement Macron les
Français ont tous supporté ils ont
supporté vos approximations quand tu
l'utilisation des masques que des
membres de votre gouvernement affirmés
inutiles avant-hier obligatoire hier et
recommandé aujourd'hui ou même le
scandale de l'affaire McKinsey
aujourd'hui vous conditionnez les
Français à l'idée d'un rationnement
énergétique avec une mise en scène qui
je dois le dire et pitoyable avec des
ministres qui viennent en col roulé
au bilan vous rouvrez les centrales à
charbon mais de qui mais vous avez à
telle opposition aussi manifestement
madame la Première ministre de qui se
moque-t-on gouverner c'est prévoir
comment le dit souvent gouverner c'est
construire l'avenir au rassemblement
national nous avions anticipé cela en
misant sur le nucléaire plutôt que sur
vos éoliennes qui brassent du vent quand
il y en a et vos panneaux solaires qui
doivent probablement hiberner en ce
moment
pendant je ne suis pas amnésique mais
rappelez-vous que vous avez fermé des
centrales nucléaires pendant ce temps
les Français les plus modestes se
serrent la ceinture dorment dans leur
voiture ou sous des ponts mais vous vous
accueillez l'océan Viking à Toulon et
ses ONG complices de ce désastre
humanitaire vous logez vous nourrissez
des migrants qui en guise de
remerciements ont pris la poudre
d'escampette comme un bras d'honneur
adressé à nos institutions impuissantes
et débordée
pendant que de nombreux Français peinent
à trouver du travail Vous vous voulez
faire appel à toujours plus de main
d'oeuvre étrangères au lieu d'accepter
notre proposition d'inciter les
entreprises à augmenter les salaires de
10% en exonérant cette augmentation de
charge décidément rien n'est cohérent
dans votre politique
mais cette mascarade aurait pu se
limiter à votre incohérence et bien non
vous avez bénéficié de la duplicité des
fausses oppositions vous avez bénéficié
de la duplicité de la nups qui lors de
la présidentielle appelée à voter pour
vous la Nupe ostraciste qui préfère
retirer un texte plutôt que d'accepter
la voix de l'opposition qui aurait fait
passer le texte en faveur de la
réintégration des soignants
alors naufrage politique et qui tentent
de protéger leurs arrières si si et là
et de sauver quelques éléments de leur
puzzle incomplet chronique d'une mort
politique annoncée les alertes aussi à
voter pour vous au second tour de la
présidentielle et qui récidive en
refusant de voter la première motion de
censure par peur peut-être de perdre
leur mandat
nous au rassemblement national nous
sommes cohérents nous avons d'ailleurs
voté la première motion de censure qui
n'est pas dans notre mouvement car nous
travaillons pour le bien-être des
Français et nous n'avons pas peur de
perdre notre place de députés madame la
Première ministre ce soir sa chef donc
un cycle de 10 49-3 la Nupe c'est les
républicains peuvent dormir en paix car
leur crainte de faire tomber le
gouvernement et de retourner aux urnes
pour élire une nouvelle Assemblée
nationale n'aura pas lieu aujourd'hui
l'émotion de censure de la nuque ce sont
des leurs une parodie dont on
rassemblement national nous avons pu
croire à un moment à leur sincérité
aujourd'hui les masques tombent et nous
ne participerons pas à cette comédie
Adèle Arte fin de la pièce de théâtre le
rideau tombe et nous ne voterons pas la
motion de censure en vous souhaitant un
joyeux Noël
je vous remercie la parole
est un Monsieur David Guiraud pour la
France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
il n'est pas question pour nous madame
la Première ministre de laisser faire
il est pas question pour nous de d'agir
comme si tout ce qui se passait dans nos
institutions étaient normal il est pas
question pour nous
de faire comme si ce qui était légal le
49-3 était juste raisonnable parce que
vous savez à l'école on explique aux
enfants que ce qui garantit la
démocratie c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs on m'a expliqué à moi enfin que
l'exécutif c'est-à-dire vous était censé
exécuter la loi une loi élaborée par le
pouvoir législatif c'est-à-dire nous les
parlementaires et pourtant
regardez-vous
tout est à l'envers
regardez ce que vous faites
10 fois le 49,3 c'est-à-dire l'abus
complètement démesurée d'un outil conçu
pour piétiner l'Assemblée nationale
vous justifier ce saccage permanent du
travail parlementaire avec un argument
assez étonnant vous nous dites qu'après
tout c'est une tradition dans la 5e
République et que le 49-3
d'autres l'ont bien fait
mais vous avez une tradition sélective
parce que moi je connais une autre
coutume républicaine
une tradition que vous avez pas respecté
depuis 30 ans chaque gouvernement qui a
été nommé a demandé la confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale
vous n'avez pas demandé cette confiance
comment osez-vous alors vous indignez de
cette motion de censure alors que la
motion de censure rappelle justement
l'essentiel que vous essayez d'esquiver
c'est que les représentants du peuple
n'ont pas confiance en vous
cette motion de censure replace la
discussion là où vous avez tenté de
l'arrêter
cette discussion c'est que vous n'avez
pas de majorité politique ici pour faire
la loi et puisque vous n'avez pas de
majorité politique
vous auriez pu partager la décision mais
vous avez décidé de confisquer le
pouvoir
vous élaborez la loi sans nous sous les
applaudissements d'une minorité
présidentielle qui a si peu de
profondeur politiques pour acclamer ses
propres bourreaux avec je dois le
reconnaître un certain talent
j'ai entendu que le 49-3 transcendait la
démocratie que les crises étaient
multidimensionnelles je ne savais pas si
j'étais à l'Assemblée nationale ou dans
Matrix
mais il n'empêche que la réalité la même
c'est que vous décidez seul dans le
secret dans le silence feutrer des
cabinets ministériels précisément le
seul endroit où vous savez que personne
ne vous contestera ou vous savez que
personne ne sera la voie contre vous
vous gouvernez dans l'ombre de la
démocratie et oui nous nous refusons de
cautionner d'une quelconque manière que
ce soit cette confiscation de la
souveraineté populaire notre motion de
censure affirme qu'ici est la lumière
ici dans cette assemblée et le débat
public ouvert à tous les citoyens auquel
ils peuvent participer regarder et donc
se faire un avis éclairé sur les
questions de notre pays nous ne faisons
au fond
que remettre de l'ordre en affirmant le
rôle premier de l'Assemblée dans
l'élaboration de nos lois et oui nous
utilisons aussi le temps donné par la
motion de censure pour parler de ces
débats que vous avez confisqué avec le
49-3 parce que si nous ne faisions pas
ces motion de censure alors nous
n'aurions jamais pu parler en hémicycle
par exemple pendant le projet de loi de
finances de notre école
cette même école qui ne s'effondre pas
aujourd'hui pour une seule raison le
courage et l'abnégation des personnels
et des enseignants que nous tenons à
saluer à remercier
il mérite comme tous les fonctionnaires
de ce pays des pays raisonnables des
effectifs corrects ne serait-ce que pour
pouvoir instruire correctement nos
propres enfants sans motion de censure
pas de mots non plus pour nos
collectivités locales pour nos mairie
qui dans la sixième puissance économique
mondiale
doivent interrompre le fonctionnement
d'infrastructures essentielle c'est même
collectivité que vous interprétez encore
à brutaliser contre la vie du Parlement
en passant de force la suppression de la
CVAE c'est-à-dire de les condamner
toujours plus à moins de marge de Manor
financière et donc à moi de marge de
liberté d'actions politiques dans ce qui
est censé être la première le premier
échelon de notre démocratie impossible
aussi sans motion de censure de
mentionner les millions de Français
que vous jetez dans la pauvreté
l'augmentation des prix rend impossible
la vie digne pour des millions de nos
concitoyens les privent d'accès aux
besoins essentiels mais elle les prive
aussi de ce qui fait nous des êtres
humains c'est-à-dire des petits plaisirs
de la vie des plaisirs modèles
mais tellement important car combien de
Français ne pourront pas cette année
mettre un cadeau ne serait-ce que pour
les enfants au pied du sapin
combien vivront encore cette année là
honte et l'humiliation ce sentiment
terrible et destructeur de ne pas être à
la hauteur parce que le système les bras
et vous vous êtes là
presque heureux vous êtes là à nous
répéter que ça va car l'inflation je
vous cite est la plus faible d'Europe
dissimulant alors volontairement que le
revenu réel des Français enregistrer la
baisse la plus importante de l'OCDE au
premier trimestre 2022 parce que vous
distribuez des chèques et que quand vous
avez arrêté le chèque d'une manière ou
d'une autre comme vous allez le faire
bientôt avec l'essence et l'électricité
au début de l'année prochaine tout
s'effondre pour ceux qui maintenaient
encore la tête sous le raison pour
laquelle l'augmentation des salaires
reste la bataille principale dans ce
pays
les gens ont froid madame la Première
ministre
il tombe malade
parce que dans leur logement il fait
parfois 12 degrés dans la salle de bain
14 dans le salon 16 degrés dans la
chambre
les gens ont froid
ils tombent malades et ils font des
heures de queue ces derniers temps j'ai
des médecins débordés notamment dans les
zones où il y a plus beaucoup de
médecins ou dans des urgences saturées
toute la chaîne de santé est
actuellement en train d'être secouer une
nouvelle fois
les gens ont froid pas par magie madame
borne
les gens au froid parce qu'il y a des
courants d'air qui passent dans leur
logement ils ont froid parce qu'on n'a
pas fait la rénovation thermique de leur
bâtiment et ils auront froid parce que
vous avez annulé un vote de l'Assemblée
nationale qui proposait 10 milliards
pour faire la transition énergétique et
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
prouvant-la à ce moment précis qu'il y a
un lien intime entre la case de notre
démocratie et la classe sociale dans ce
pays
les Français
sont pauvres collègues
et que dire de nos enfants
un jeune de 18
29 ans sur 5 et pauvre 1 sur 5 ça vous
fait sourire pas moi le taux de pauvreté
des mineurs est passé de 8,7% de 2004 à
11,5 % en 2019 voilà la réalité que vous
refusez d'accepter vous avez abandonné
nos petits la pauvreté n'est pas un
phénomène magique la pauvreté est sous
nos yeux parce que vous avez refusé
pendant le débat parlementaire une
allocation d'autonomie qui aurait permis
de sortir de la pauvreté des millions
des jeunes de ce pays les mêmes
précaires que vous apprêtez à faire
remplir les caisses de l'État pourtant
richissime en exigeant deux qu'il paye
la crise avec la réforme de l'assurance
chômage ou celle du travail c'est-à-dire
des milliards de cadeaux 150 milliards
distribuer aux entreprises payées
par des gens qui se tuent au boulot la
réforme des retraites c'est le
corbillard après une vie de labeur
pendant que Total et les autres groupes
richissent bénéficient de votre
gentillesse
votre gouvernement en définitive et
celui du désordre et de l'instabilité
vous nous trimbalez de crises en crise
vous assommez les consciences vous
étouffez les débats en participant à
créer des tempêtes sociales et
écologiques et lorsque la tempête arrive
vous nous ordonnez de serrer les rangs
de nous taire
de ne plus rien contester
notre pays est en errance
percuté par vos crises à répétition
alors nous voulons bien affronter les
tempêtes
mais nous posons la seule question qui
va peut-être au fond la seule question
que se pose les Français d'accord pour
l'autodère d'accord pour les tempêtes
mais à quand le soleil
à quand la recherche du bonheur commun
c'est précisément parce que vous êtes
inapte à répondre à cette question que
nous vous demandons aujourd'hui encore
une fois et jusqu'au bout de partir
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Véronique
clovagier pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général cher collègues pour
la 10e fois depuis deux mois vous avez
eu recours la première ministre à
l'article 49-3 de notre Constitution sur
les projets de loi de finances et sur
les projets de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale c'est vrai que
finalement avec la majorité et le
gouvernement les jeudis de décembre se
suivent et se ressemblent pour y faire
une série finalement madame la Première
ministre les jeudis de décembre jeudi 8
décembre commission mixte paritaire sur
la loi de programmation des finances
publiques ajournée et huitième article
49-3 jeudi 15 décembre de nouveau
commissions mixte paritaire sur la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
n'ont pas à journée mais non conclusive
et dixième article 49.3 or au 49-3 un
Cesson suivent un variable l'émotion de
censure de la nups d'où notre présence
ici ce samedi pour défendre nos
positions sur ce budget le moment où
vous déclenchez madame la Première
ministre l'article 49-3 est un acte
politique particulièrement regrettable
car en 4 minutes vous avez de nouveau
privé jeudi dernier les députés de leurs
droits de parole mais ce qui est
extraordinaire sont les raisons par
lesquelles vous justifiez recourir un
article 49-3 successivement vous avez
donné comme argument lors des premières
fois où vous avez mis en œuvre l'article
49-3 que je vous cite tous les groupes
de position nous ont fait savoir qu'il
voteront contre ce PLF ensuite notamment
lors de la nouvelle lecture de ce PLF
l'argument était qu'aucun groupe
d'opposition ne vous avait fait
connaître une évolution de sa position
sur son vote finale et maintenant pour
la lecture définitive vous nous dites
que nous avons aussi trop souvent trouvé
porte-close et vous ajoutez sur le
budget nous ne pouvons pas trouver de
compromis si les oppositions craignent
ainsi de se compromettre mais madame la
première ministrelaçons l'église au
milieu du village c'est ce que nous
disons chez nous dans le Perche dans le
pays d'où je douche et le Pays d'Auge
même si l'Église ne se déplace jamais
quelquefois il faut la recycler au
milieu de village et si vous avez
recours à cet outil constitutionnel
c'est simplement pour une seule une
unique raison c'est que vous n'avez pas
de majorité donc n'essayez pas de
reporter la responsabilité sur les
groupes d'opposition assumez de devoir
composer avec les oppositions si
effectivement vous voulez aboutir mais
quand vous ne voulez pas composer
effectivement vous n'aboutissez pas j'en
veux par exemple pour preuve votre refus
de trouver une voie de passage sur la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques sur ce texte les députés et
les sénateurs les républicains ont
toujours été très clairs et très
déterminés à aboutir pour autant votre
majorité et votre gouvernement ont
continué de balayer d'un revers demain
nos propositions refusant dans les actes
le compromis que vous réclamez pourtant
dans vos discours et vous indiquez
madame Nadia hey que il n'y avait pas eu
de proposition il y a eu des
propositions aux indiquées par ailleurs
qu'elle n'était pas suffisamment
documentées voilà c'est une question
tout simplement d'appréciation de votre
part
preuve en est également vous n'avez
retenu dans ce PLF que très peu
d'amendements des députés et sénateurs
des groupes d'opposition et que dire de
votre amendement qui est une réforme du
compte personnel de formation sans débat
et en catimini c'est amendement déposé à
la dernière minute samedi dernier sans
même que le rapporteur général n'en
prenne connaissance n'a pas fait
l'unanimité même au sein du groupe
Renaissance la présidente Aurore Bergé
son est elle-même émue en déclarant
c'est une méthode qui ne doit pas se
reproduire le Conseil constitutionnel
quant à lui pourrait considérer cette
mesure comme un cavalier alors oui avec
votre méthode nous avons été privées de
débat sur des sujets d'importance
capitale les finances des collectivités
territoriales la défense la mission
travail solidarité éducation nationale
et bien d'autres sujets encore j'attire
votre attention sur les risques
résultant de cette situation en effet
que les députés soient d'ailleurs de la
majorité ou de l'opposition ils sont
également des relais d'information sur
le terrain d'un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives et de débats
contribuer à diminuer les échanges voire
à les supprimer ou les rendre
inexistants de ce fait privé d'un
certain nombre d'informations
relatives à la mise en place de vos
politiques publiques les députés ne
seront pas indien comme les années
précédentes sur les territoires d'un
certain nombre de dispositions
législatives tout cela accentue une
crise de confiance dans la vie politique
et contribue à accroître le fossé entre
les citoyens et le monde politique sur
le fond je ne vais pas ici rappeler
toutes les raisons de notre opposition à
ce PLF nous divergences sont notoires
m'envoie si quelques-unes les hypothèses
macroéconomiques retenus par votre
gouvernement tout d'abord son
manifestement insincèrent vous campez
coûte que coûte sur une hypothèse de
croissance de 1% pour 2023 quand le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques ainsi que
tous les instituts vous disent qu'elle
est trop optimiste et donc intenable
c'est maintenant même le président de la
République lui-même qui précise que le
taux de croissance pour 2023 devrait se
situer entre
0,5% et
0,7%. une autre divergence concerne le
niveau de déficit de 164,9 milliards
d'euros avec un endettement votre corps
votre gouvernement ne veut toujours pas
écouter nous écouter et nous déplorons
plus que jamais votre renoncement à la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques qui nous
conduit dans le mur de l'indette et ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce n'est pas
moi je veux citer simplement le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques dans son
avis de septembre
2022 qui souligne que le retour à des
niveaux de dettes garantissant à la
France de disposer de marge de manœuvre
suppose un effort collectif reposant sur
la maîtrise de la dépense couplée à la
recherche d'une plus grande efficacité
de celle-ci c'est également le FMI il y
a quelques semaines qui viennent lancer
un avertissement non pas à l'Italie non
pas à la Grèce à la France à notre pays
pour le dérapage incontrôlé de ces
comptes publics et le 2 décembre dernier
c'est l'agence de notation Standard en
course qui tire un coup de ce Mons en
plaçant la note de la France sous
surveillance négative la puissance
publique française a décidé de continuer
sa gabgie de dépenses et de dettes et
celle-ci a augmenté en trois mois de 40
milliards euros 40 milliards d'euros
atteignant ainsi les
2956,8 milliards d'euros au troisième
trimestre 2022 c'est-à-dire nous
rapprochons de ce seuil symbolique de
3000 milliards l'Agence France Trésor
dans son programme de financement de la
dette française pour 2023 indique le
V300 milliards d'euros sur les marchés
dont 270 milliards d'euros un moyen et
long terme pour 2023 la France sera
alors le premier émetteur net de la zone
euro le premier émetteur net de la zone
euro le fait par ailleurs que la moitié
de notre dette souveraine soit détenue
par des fonds étrangers devraient vous
inquiéter devrait vous interpeller
une autre raison concerne la
préoccupation majeure de tous les
Français et de toutes les entreprises
qui est le coût de l'énergie
préoccupation insuffisamment satisfaite
par ce PLF effectivement en 2023 les
tarifs d'électricité et de gaz proposé
aux entreprises seront extrêmement plus
élevées que ceux qui existaient en 2022
et en fait les alternatives de nos
entreprises seront délicates car alors
que les carnets de commandes sont pleins
quasiment toutes les entreprises nous le
disent certaines devront arrêter ou
diminuer leur activité c'est tout de
même un comble que le redémarrage
économique après covid se heurte
finalement au mécanisme du prix de
l'énergie je pense au boulanger au
boucher aux industriels et à tant
d'autres encore qui se trouveront en
difficulté dans quelques mois j'avais
hier dans ma permanence un chef
d'entreprise à la tête de d'une
entreprise de métallurgie avec qui je
regardais finalement les mécanismes qui
pourront s'appliquer à sa situation
en fait même avec un mécanisme de
soutien certes significative pour son
entreprise le reste à charge de son
entreprise sera quasiment multipliée par
deux et demi 3 c'est-à-dire que sa
facture annuelle d'énergie qui est
aujourd'hui de 140 000 euros passera à
000 euros après net des soutiens de
l'État et par ailleurs la situation très
différente de l'entreprise à l'autre en
fonction notamment des durées et des
dates d'expiration des contrats va créer
des situations de compétitivité et de
concurrence différentes alors madame la
Première ministre la seule solution et
il faut agir rapidement c'est
véritablement de décorer les le prix de
l'électricité et du gaz le plus
rapidement possible et de sortir de ce
mécanisme européen qui nous emmène à une
dérive sans nom
je le redis vous avez refusé toutes les
avancées de vos oppositions et du Sénat
pour autant les députés les républicains
de voteront pas cette énième motion de
censure nous avons certes des
divergences avec le gouvernement que ce
soit en matière de finance publique de
politique énergétique ou de politique
migratoires mais nous l'avons déjà
rappelé le jour où nous voulons voter
une motion de censure et je le redis à
mon collègue du rassemblement national
nous la déposerons nous-mêmes sur notre
nom ce n'est pas d'actualité ce n'était
pas d'actualité jusqu'à maintenant car
l'intérêt du pays demeure notre boussole
en revanche nous saisirons dans quelques
heures le Conseil constitutionnel en
raison notamment de l'insincérité des
prévisions économiques de ce projet de
loi de l'absence de vote de la loi de
règlement du non-respect du droit
d'amendement des parlementaires et des
injustices dans le calcul de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement voté dans
l'article 12 avant de conclure je
voudrais remercier le président de la
commission des finances le rapporteur
général pour leur engagement dans une
période intense et difficile à et à
l'aune de 2023 pour cette dernière
expression à cette tribune pour 2022 je
forme je formule 3 voeux le premier et
que la France puisse rapidement
déconnecter le prix de l'électricité de
celui du gaz au niveau européen car il y
a un besoin au niveau des entreprises
très fort inattente le second est madame
la Première ministre que vous écoutiez
les députés les républicains nous sommes
et resteront dans une démarche
d'opposition constructive pour servir
notre pays le troisième est que vous
renonciez que vous renoncez à
l'utilisation de l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution en 2023 est en dés
systématiquement vers le compromis j'en
termine enfin en souhaitant de tout cœur
à chacune à chacun de très belles fêtes
de fin d'année je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Pascal le camp pour le groupe
démocrate
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances va revenir je pense
monsieur rapporteur général chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
partager avec vous avant d'attaquer le
sujet du jour une pensée émue pour les 5
enfants et les 5 adultes qui ont péri
dans le l'incendie de Vaulx-en-Velin
avant-hier et en particulier pour leur
famille et leurs proches
nous y voici enfin
oserais-je dire réuni pour le dernier
vote sur ce budget 2022
dans un hémicycle certes visiblement
très clairement
pour doter la France en ce premier jour
de vacances de Noël de son budget pour
l'année prochaine
je le prends pour un très bon signe un
très beau cadeau pour nos concitoyens
je veux dire en effet tout le soutien
des députés démocrates à ce projet de
loi de finances
construit parfois avec difficulté mais
toujours dans le souci de l'intérêt
général
quel que soit le banc d'où viennent les
contributions au débat
ces crédits s'élèvent à 455 milliards
d'euros
nous le soutenons d'abord parce que
c'est un budget qui protège
efficacement nominage nos entreprises et
nos collectivités contre la hausse des
prix de l'énergie et l'inflation de
manière générale nous avons ainsi
prolongé le bouclier tarifaire pour ceux
d'entre eux qui ont le plus grand besoin
ce dispositif à d'ores et déjà permis de
limiter l'inflation de plus de 3 points
en 2022 c'est grâce à ce choix que la
France est le pays de la zone euro ou
l'inflation et la plus faible
aujourd'hui où le pouvoir d'achat a été
le mieux protégé
nous agissons aussi contrairement à ce
qui a été dit pour les collectivités
dont nous avons entendu les difficultés
à l'initiative de ma très chère collègue
lise manié et de l'ensemble du groupe
horizon nous avons ainsi transformé le
filet de sécurité créé par cette même
assemblée en juillet en filet de soutien
le dispositif recentré sur les seuls
prix de l'énergie leur a aussi été
ouvert notamment via la suppression de
la condition de baisse de l'excédent
brut de fonctionnement nous saluons
également
l'amortisseur pour les prix de
l'électricité la destination des PME et
des collectivités qui ne peuvent
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire
nous serons à vos côtés pour son
déploiement madame la Premier ministre
et si besoin pour l'adapter aux besoins
de nos PME elles sont à notre écoute
constante
nos bouchers nos boulangers nos
pâtissiers nos poissonniers nos artisans
ont besoin de notre soutien et ils
trouveront toujours à leur côté ils nous
trouvons toujours à leur côté dans
l'étang de houle comme dirait mon
collègue Jimmy j'ai moi-même participé
il y a quelques jours comme ma collègue
m'a dit
à une rencontre avec les députés de la
Vienne tous mes collègues de la Vienne
avec les artisans du département à la
CMA autour de sa présidence
pâtissière elle-même du préfet et de
représentants de la DG FIP en présence
du directeur général du plus gros
énergéticien de notre département à une
rencontre de clarification du dispositif
que nous avons décidé de mettre en place
à leur attention je salue ici tous les
efforts de dialogue et de simplification
qui l'ont allégé afin d'accélérer le
transfert des montants attendus le plus
rapidement possible vers les entreprises
toutes les aides que j'ai citées et les
autres mises en place en parallèle sont
nécessaires pour réduire les effets
néfastes de la hausse des prix d'énergie
afin de préserver notre tissu productif
l'État joue ainsi parfaitement son rôle
protecteur a une atténuant le choc de
cette hausse en la lissant dans le temps
toutes ces aides si elles sont
nécessaires dans le contexte inédit que
nous connaissons ont un coût important à
court terme pour le groupe démocrate les
finances publiques sont un enjeu
primordial de souveraineté et de
prospérité cependant nous avons aussi la
conviction qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
chemin que celui du soutien indéfectible
au ménage aux collectivités et aux
entreprises la conviction que les
abandonnés maintenant nous coûteraient
bien plus cher à long terme par la
destruction de temps entier de notre
appareil productif
néanmoins compte tenu de l'état de nos
finances publiques et de l'épée de
Damoclès de la dette qui plane au dessus
de nos têtes nous ne pouvons pas nous
exonérer de tout effort à la matière
nous devons adopter une véritable
trajectoire de rétablissement d'un
équilibre des comptes publics comme le
propose la loi de programmation des
finances publiques cher à notre cher
Gabriel et plus encore nous y tenir
ce PLF n'est pas seulement un prélève de
réponse à la conjoncture c'est aussi un
vecteur important de notre politique en
témoigne par exemple la suppression en
deux temps de la CVAE qui doit améliorer
la compétitivité de nos entreprises et
partant développer l'emploi
je ne vous listerai pas tous les bons
côtés de ce budget je voudrais m'arrêter
un instant en rapporteur spécial au sein
de la commission des finances sur celui
de l'agriculture notre vision pour
l'agriculture est simple et ce n'est pas
le ministre phéno qui me contredira la
souveraineté alimentaire française
passera par la protection des
agriculteurs et des agriculteurrices et
surtout de leur revenu l'adaptation de
la ferme France au changement climatique
et une transformation des pratiques
agricoles ce PLF est en premier lieu
celui de la mise en œuvre de la loi de
l'assurance récolte une révolution
copernicienne où l'État remplit sa part
avec ce budget qui sécurise la
contribution de 560 millions d'euros de
la solidité de la solidarité nationale
une véritable réassurance pour les
acteurs du monde agricole
des députés démocrates vous ont ainsi
proposé un ensemble d'amendements
fiscaux qui vont dans cette direction
comme la prorogation de la déduction
pour épargne de précautions ou encore
l'augmentation du plafond de
l'exonération pour la transmission des
terres agricoles à 500000 euros en
échange d'une prolongation de la durée
de détention
la transmission et l'installation de
nouveaux agriculteurs souvent bien
formés et non n'y non issus du milieu
agricole seront au cœur du pacte loi
d'orientation agricole nous serons à vos
côtés monsieur le ministre féno vous le
savez sur ce sujet
excusez-moi j'ai un début de rhume j'ai
du mal à parler
au-delà de l'exemple de l'agriculture
nous avons aussi pu engager de nombreux
débats dans le cadre de ce PLF je pense
en premier lieu à la question de la
fiscalité du capital notamment
s'agissant des plus-values immobilières
en zone tendue nous n'avons pas réussi à
vous convaincre totalement sur ce sujet
nous continuerons d'y travailler en nous
inspirant de ce qui peut être fait dans
d'autres pays européens nous sommes
confiants de vous voir un jour rejoindre
nos constats et nos propositions
ce PLF a aussi été marqué comme chacun
sait par le débat sur les super profits
nous avons avec le président Mattei
proposé un amendement permettant de
taxer non pas les profits mais leur
distribution que ce soit par dividendes
ou rachat d'actions car le problème
n'est pas tant le profit nous l'avons
bien entendu
mais ce qui en effet le profit est
vertueux en fait si les réinvestis par
exemple dans la transition écologique
redistribuer aux salariés ou en hausse
de salaire
ce n'est pas l'approche qui a été
choisie nous le regrettons nous
continuons d’être persuadés que la
taxation des super dividendes est juste
économiquement et socialement je
voudrais toutefois saluer
car l'Europe c'est l'ADN des députés
modem et démocrate comme vous le savez
l'adoption des dispositifs sur lesquels
les États européens sont entendus en
septembre dernier la taxation des super
profits se sont étendues la taxation
pardon des super profits des
énergéticiens et la contribution sur les
rentes inframarginales permettront de
lever environ 10 milliards d'euros
finançant une part importante des
mesures de soutien au ménage et aux
entreprises que nous avons votées
nos débats ont été certes un peu
perturbés par le recours comme beaucoup
l'ambitionné à la ligne à 3 de l'article
49 de la Constitution et le cas d'André
un peu particulier auquel c'est 5
recours et c'est ça que motions de
censure qui ont suivi nous ont contraint
je voudrais ici tout particulièrement
m'arrêter sur les critiques aussi
récurrentes qu'injuste à l'égard du
fameux 49-3 et répondre peut-être à
certaines allégations de mes collègues
j'ai eu la chance d'être invité en
septembre dernier au musée de la
tapisserie d'Aubusson
vous étiez avec moi alors pour fêter les
101 ans d'un illustre ministre
socialiste du président Mitterrand
que vous connaissez tous premiers
conseillé de la Cour des comptes je veux
parler d'André Chandernagor né dans ma
belle ville de Civray dans la Vienne et
fils de commerçant comme moi
pendant près de deux heures devant un
parterre de 200 personnes micro en main
et confortablement loint installé dans
un fauteuil il nous a raconté sa vie par
le détail et en particulier la rédaction
à deux mains avec Michel Debré de
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution du 4
octobre 1958
l'alinéa qu'il avait conçu est prévu
qu'ils avaient ensemble conçu et prévu
justement dès l'écriture de la
constitution de la 4e République
non pas pour
piétiner l'Assemblée nationale comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
Giraud mais au contraire en anticipation
des situations de majorité relative pour
permettre à notre état de continuer à
fonctionner dans les cas où le débat ne
permet pas d'aboutir à un consensus
et une fois cette démonstration terminée
sans un an devant pendant deux heures il
parle une fois sa démonstration terminée
pendant sa main vers moi qui était dans
le public il ajouta avec le brin de
malice qu'on lui connaît toi tu vas pas
tarder en avoir besoin
et tu es pas devin mais sans doute
prémonitoire la situation actuelle
répond exactement à l'esprit qui a guidé
le constituant en 1958 une situation où
parfois aucune majorité absolue ne se
dégage à l'Assemblée mais il faut
pouvoir avancer en amour le 49-3 et là
pour permettre à l'État de fonctionner
dans une situation de majorité relative
comme celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui nos constitutionnalistes de
1958 était tout simplement très avisé
ainsi chacun aura compris comme nous
pouvons le voir dans de nombre de
démocratie autour de nous
que le consensus ne peut s'obtenir que
si chacun arrive autour de la table avec
des marges de négociation comme je l'ai
connu moi-même en Scandinavie le travail
doit toujours être fait en amont si
chacun pense qu'il détient seule la
vérité et n'accepte aucune main tendue
ou offre alternative alors le 49-3 sera
à nouveau le seul outil permettant de
faire avancer la France je veux rester
optimiste
c'est un rapport d'étonnement d'un
député qui n'a que 6 mois d'existence je
veux rester optimiste pour la majorité
comme pour les oppositions nul doute le
travail de fond qu'on a réalisé en
commission depuis six mois dans cette
nouvelle mandature et là je remercie et
le rapporteur général et le président de
la commission des finances j'ai appris
avec eux nul doute que ce travail
qu'on a réalisé dans en commission mais
aussi en séance comme nous venons de le
voir sur sur la loi sur l'accélération
des ENR ou la loopnie nul doute que tout
ce travail permettra dans les exercices
à venir de légiférer par plus de
consensus permettant ainsi à plus de
débats d'aboutir d'aller jusqu'au bout
et à de loin d'être voté avec des
concessions de la part de tous c'est
indispensable mais avec une seule et
unique boussole pour chacun l'intérêt
général des Français
typiquement le consensus on l'aura
j'espère tous par exemple demain
après-midi tous ensemble derrière les
Bleus
je pousse un peu le trait mais on doit
pouvoir arriver à des choses chers
collègues plus sérieusement il faut un
budget à la France et aujourd'hui il
faut se budget à la France celui que
nous allons voter tous ensemble que nous
avons voté tout ça nous en sommes
uniquement convaincus chez les démocrate
car il répond aux besoins de nos
concitoyens pour faire face au
ralentissement économique à l'inflation
et à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
madame la Première ministre vous avez
notre confiance nous attendons beaucoup
de vous vous le savez vous savez aussi
en retour que vous vous pouvez compter
sur le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant comme force de proposition
et de soutien nous ne voterons pas la
motion proposée je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Boris Vallaud
président du groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers et chers collègues dans
quelques minutes sans doute votre budget
sera-t-il adopté il y a des suspens qui
n'en sont pas vraiment
j'imagine le moment même où nous nous
retrouvons pour l'examen d'une dixième
motion de censure consécutive à votre
dixième 49.3 alors que ce profil la
trêve des confiseurs selon l'expression
consacrée depuis 1874
l'ambivalence des sentiments qui madame
la Première ministre peuvent être les
vôtres d'un côté mais je n'y crois guère
pose des bateaux Manimal tristesse
et nous allons vous manquer affreusement
parce que vous aviez manifestement pris
goût à ces rendez-vous nocturnes ou de
fin de semaine des rendez-vous presque
clandestins ou quasi confidentielle
qui d'une certaine manière vous arrachez
aux tête-à-tête avec le président de la
République avec ce fameux il décide vous
exécutez peut-être parce que vous aviez
le sentiment de décider mais non vous
n'étiez que l'instrument de
l'obstination présidentielle de sa
curieuse conception du débat public de
la concertation et une fine de la
démocratie il décide et nous exécutons
rien n'a véritablement changé depuis le
dernier quinquennat déjà Macron pointait
sous Emmanuel la démocratie oui mais la
démocratie expéditive
d'un autre côté j'ai la crainte que vous
ayez le sentiment sincère peut-être du
devoir accompli la fierté même d'avoir
surmonté les obstacles du débat
parlementaire qui se dressaient sur
votre chemin d'avoir été plus forte ou
plus maligne que vos oppositions d'avoir
fait montre de votre force de caractère
à ceux de vos collègues qui espèrent de
votre chute leur propre sacre d'où vous
êtes en quelques sommes sauvées
peut-être vous êtes-vous trouvé à Bill
rusé manœuvrière courageuse audacieuse
et même un brin culotté que sais-je j'ai
peur que vous nourricier l'illusion d'un
accomplissement d'avoir réussi quelque
chose de sortir grandi de l'épisode en
vérité qu'elle a miteux que nous venons
de vivre
car madame la Première ministre vous
avez surtout infligé à la représentation
nationale une humiliation sans précédent
dans un contexte lui-même sans prétestan
de majorité relative issue des urnes
notre guide et notre maître vous n'avez
tenu aucun compte de cette nouvelle
donne alors que se poser à vous et au
président de la République cette
question simple à quoi les Français nous
demandent-ils de renoncer puisque nous
n'avons pas demandé clair pour appliquer
notre programme vous avez à travers nous
infliger camouflé sur camouflé à toutes
celles et tous ceux de nos concitoyens
qui espérait du débat parlementaire et
qui ont cru à vos promesses de gouverner
autrement
car il y a derrière chacune et chacun
d'entre nous des femmes et les hommes
des ouvriers et des soignants des
retraités et des chefs d'entreprise des
collectivités locales et des
associations qui attendent chaque année
c'est les Bab budgétaires qui portent
haut ce moment de reddition des comptes
vous avez déçu frustré et sans un doute
généré beaucoup d'incompréhensions et à
tout dire je le crains de colère parmi
nos compatriotes dans un moment qui
pourtant appelle plus que jamais à la
Concorde
l'Assemblée nationale
gouvernement paraît l'ignorer n'est pas
recroquevillé sur lui-même mais à
l'écoute permanente du pays député de
tous les groupes je crois pouvoir parler
au nom de chacun de mes collègues tous
les bancs nous préparons l'examen des
textes et en particulier des textes
budgétaires avec minutie et au terme de
très nombreuses auditions auditions des
organisations professionnelles et
syndicats des associations des
universitaires par dizaines par
centaines même nous entendons les
interpellations multiples qui surgissent
des profondeurs du pays les inquiétudes
et les questions auxquelles nous nous
appelons à répondre tant bien que mal il
est vrai
les arguments et les amendements que
nous livrons à la délibération
démocratique ne sont pas le fruit de nos
caprices ou de nos humeurs nous vous en
déplaisent mais la traduction concrète
de ce travail de représentation car être
élu ne suffit pas à faire de nous des
représentants du peuple c'est par
l'écoute par le dialogue quotidien avec
nos concitoyens et concitoyens avec des
habitants et des habitants de nos
circonscriptions personnellement mais
aussi avec tous les collectifs tous les
corps intermédiaires que nous donnons à
nos mandats le caractère représentatif
nous sommes par notre façon même de
légiférer les garants de cette
démocratie continue que vous obstruez
aujourd'hui
et après cette écoute après saisi
nombrables dialogue vient le moment ici
de la délibération du peuple assemblée
et depuis toujours ce peuple assemblé a
comme première prérogative le
consentement à l'impôt or que
n'avons-nous fait ces dernières semaines
le premier budget de la Nation celui de
l'éducation nationale qui concerne
chaque famille tous les enfants de
France plus d'un million de
professionnels d'enseignants et de
personnels de l'Éducation nationale qui
œuvre chaque jour à construire l'avenir
de notre patrie pas un mot pas un mot
n'aura résonné dans cette hémicycle
cette année à son sujet peu importe
finalement ce que nous aurons dit les
enseignants et les enseignants que nous
avons écouté les parents d'élèves que
nous avons reçu les organisations
d'élèves qui nous ont interpellés peu
importe les demandes d'éclaircissement
les propositions les controverses qui
émanent notre société pas une des
paroles pas une de ces attentes nous
retrouver des côtes dans cette hémicycle
rendu muet par votre brutalité
un autre exemple tout aussi saisissant
le logement le logement au cœur de la
vie quotidienne des Français des enjeux
de pouvoir d'achat de qualité de vie de
transition écologique d'aménagement du
territoire de mixité sociale le logement
consubstantiel de l'insertion économique
et sociale et de la refonder de la
Fondation même d'une famille n'aura
jamais été évoqué dans nos débats pas un
mot ici pour en évoquer l'urgence
pensez-vous sérieusement que les
bailleurs sociaux que nous avons reçues
que les constructeurs que nous avons
entendu que les collectivités locales
que nous avons écouté les associations
de locataires de propriétés à les zones
d'Ang qui œuvrent chaque jour pour
l'accompagnement des personnes malgées
qui nous ont interpellés à travers nous
rien à faire valoir rien à vous dire
rien à vous demander ça se décide est
civile est-elle comme nous manifestement
indigne de votre écoute et de votre
considération je crois au contraire que
beaucoup de leur propositions auraient
gagné à être débattus ici dans cette
hémicycle et les regrettable que vous y
soyez refusé
vous avez peu pro décidé seul et sans
débat de 1200 milliards de dépenses ce
n'est pas le Parlement seul qui vous
réduisez au silence ce sont les Français
eux-mêmes
n'en percevez-vous vous pas la gravité
nos nourrissez-vous pas confusément un
sentiment de honte ou à tous les mois
une forme d'un tranquillité d'esprit
vous avez esquivé des débats essentiels
que vous deviez offenses et aux Français
et nous sommes en droit de vous demander
à cette heure de nous demander à cette
heure si l'Assemblée nationale à cette
aînée conformément au plus hautes
exigences démocratiques véritablement
consenties à l'impôt et au budget de la
Nation je dois vous le dire qu'il est
permis d'en douter
vous vous plaignez d'un soi-disant
chahut vous accusez plus souvent à votre
tour les oppositions d'obstruction quand
en réalité vous imposez le silence au
débat démocratique de proche en proche
vous n'avez plus même fait semblant de
chercher à débattre vous avez des gainé
vos 49-3 plus vite que votre home comme
un Lucky Luke version rive gauche comme
un port someone Prime Minister et
puisque vous disposiez du 49-3 avec
l'impitoyable tranchant au moins
auriez-vous pu prendre le risque de
défendre vos positions le temps
d'écouter les nôtres vous avez en vérité
manqué de lucidité et de courage et en
écolointain à Beaumarchais je vous
dirais qu'il n'est que les petits hommes
pour craindre les petits débats
au final parce qu'il est le fruit
infertile d'un monologue gouvernemental
d'un tête-à-tête avec vous-même et avec
vos certitudes votre budget est un
mauvais budget qui nous répond ni à
l'urgence démocratique ni à l'urgence
sociale ni à l'urgence environnementale
et par dessus tout il est d'une
redoutable et un placable injustice que
nous ne cesserons jamais de dénoncer que
les Français par notre voie le sachent
vous allez faire payer le quoi qu'il en
coûte aux classes populaires et au
classe moyenne vouloir faire payer vous
leur ferez payer en réformant les
retraites l'assurance chômage le RSA
vous réaliserez des économies sur le dos
des chômeurs des retraités des malades
de l'école de l'hôpital des
fonctionnaires des fonctionnaires de
l'hôpital la santé justement dont le
budget cette année baissera de 0,6% à
Dieu les largesses du Ségur de la santé
quand elle éducation nationale
vous y poursuivez l'oeuvre funeste du
blanc quiisme et vous réduirez une fois
encore le nombre des fonctionnaires
comme si les moyens de l'éducation
nationale n'étaient pas criant vous
économiserez aux dépenses des
collectivités territoriales de leur
service public de leur transport des
cantines scolaires des centres de
loisirs des crèches municipales
c'est-à-dire toujours d'une manière ou
d'une autre au dépend des plus modestes
ce que vous prétendez donner d'une main
vous finissez toujours par le reprendre
de l'autre la retraite à 65 ans c'est en
cela la pire des brutalités faite à
celles et ceux qui n'ont que leur force
de travail pour vivre madame la Première
ministre vous jouez un jeu bien
dangereux avec nos institutions vous
n'aimez pas le débat vous aimez la
reddition seulement le compromis est une
méthode et vous avez été incapable de la
construire madame la Première ministre
faites vivre ce parlementarisme de fait
que les Français nous ont imposé faites
vivre la démocratie madame la Première
ministre lorsque les majorités craignent
de voir leur programme disparaître dans
une embuscade lorsque minorité sont
obligés de veiller larmes aux points
pour défendre leurs droits les plus
justes le temps se consume en
escarmouche misérable on passe sa vie à
faire faction devant des tentes
immobiles on tourne dans un cercle sans
horizon et sans air personne n'osant
aller de l'avant il n'y a plus de place
pour ses grandes et nobles batailles
d'idées qui donnent du butin même au
vaincu voilà ce cri crivé Eugène pierre
en 1902 120 ans plus tard nous sommes
toujours là puisque vous avez quelques
jours de repos madame la Première
ministre et je conclus méditer cette
phrase de Jaurès la démocratie n'est pas
fatiguée de mouvement elle est fatiguée
d'immobilité tout cela ne pas peur duré
5 ans
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
pour le prison
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
chers collègues
nous y voilà comme si le roman de cet
automne budgétaire avait été écrit à
l'avance nous nous retrouvons ce samedi
après-midi pour nous prononcer sur la
10ème motion de censure déposée par les
députés de la nupes l'avantage avec vous
chers collègues c'est que nous ne sommes
jamais vraiment déçus et encore moins
surpris ce n'est pas comme si vous ne
nous aviez pas prévenu alors pour la 10e
fois nous voilà vous écoutez on est même
discours et inlassablement tenu par les
profondeurs du gouvernement soit disant
protecteur héroïque des droits du
Parlement face à exécutif qui serait à
vous entendre sourd à toute
avertissement
alors vous mettez toutes vos forces dans
ce baroud d'honneur bien que vous le
savez perdu d'avance mais qu'importe à
vous entendre vous êtes les défenseurs
de la démocratie d'ailleurs vous êtes la
démocratie qu'importe le décalage si
important entre vos paroles et vos actes
qu'importe si vous êtes les premiers à
faire de l'obstruction à invectiver
régulièrement chaque orateur du
gouvernement ou de la majorité qui aura
l'outrecuidance de vous porter dans
cette émission la contradiction
qu'importe si c'est le son de démocratie
que vous êtes si pro à donner lors d'un
dès lors qu'elles soient en filmées et
diffusés ne s'appliquent jamais dans les
obscures sénacles de vos organes de
décision interne comme le montre votre
actualité de ces derniers jours
qu'importe bien sûr la réalité de ce que
vous avancez des procès d'intention que
vous dressez des indignations à
géométrie variable que vous assainez ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il vous faut c'est
taper fort faire du bruit et si possible
avoir une capsule vidéo à partager sur
les réseaux sociaux avec des beaux
sous-titres et des phrases chocs je
pourrais je pourrais je pourrais
continuer encore longtemps
avec les histoires contre vos positions
qui n'amusent et ne parlent plus à grand
nombre mais nos concitoyens méritent
mieux et ne nous ont pas élus à
l'Assemblée nationale en juin dernier
pour nous donner en spectacle pour
participer au concours de la meilleure
formule pour nous a donné une fois de
plus à ces débats stériles qui ne font
plus vibrer personne si ce n'est vous
ils nous ont élu chacun selon sa
sensibilité politique pour participer à
l'effort de redressement du pays et sans
doute à la qualité de la réflexion
collective je veux donc leur rappeler
que ce dixième acte participe en réalité
d'une seule et même pièce le vote d'un
budget essentiel pour la sécurité
sociale et pour l'État alors je tâcherai
d'aller à l'essentiel premièrement dire
à nos concitoyens que la situation
actuelle n'est certes pas satisfaisante
et que bien sûr déclencher l'article
49-3 n'est jamais la panacée quel que
soit les bancs sur lesquels nous
siégeons la majorité de la majorité ou
de l'opposition nous sommes tous des
élus de la nation attachées au débat et
au rôle du Parlement nous sommes tenus
de débattre dans un état d'esprit
constructif de trouver des compromis et
quand cela n'est pas possible alors il
est normal d'utiliser les possibilités
permises par la Constitution
le recours au troisième alinéa de
l'article 49 de la Constitution n'est
pas une sinécure je le disais simplement
le constat du refus du côté des
oppositions de discuter de manière
constructive d'un budget nécessaire pour
notre pays c'est votre droit le plus
strict et nous respectons cela mais il
ne faut pas mais il faut pardon le dire
et le redire sans relâche l'utilisation
du 49-3 n'est que la conséquence dès la
de l'annonce par vous opposition
d'entrée de jeu avant même que les
débats ne s'engagent que vous voteriez
contre le budget de l'État contre le
vieux budget la sécurité sociale tout
d'abord
il je veux le dire aussi nous
poursuivons le renforcement des
politiques régaliennes dans ce budget
les budgets des ministères concernés
poursuivront leur montée en puissance
que ce soit l'armée la justice
l'intérieur ou l'éducation nationale des
efforts considérables sont consentis
pour renforcer l'action régalienne de
l'État concrètement c'est plus de
policiers c'est plus de gendarmes c'est
plus de juge c'est plus de greffiers
c'est plus d'accompagnants d'élèves en
situation de handicap et c'est aussi des
enseignants beaucoup mieux payés dans le
même temps l'investissement en faveur de
la transition écologique sera accentuée
grâce à des engagements de crédit
important dans la rénovation technique
des bâtiments dans les mobilités propres
ou dans les énergies alternatives la
création d'un fond vert à destination
des collectivités territoriales dotées
de 2 milliards d'euros permettra de
renforcer le financement de la
transition écologique et ça au plus près
des territoires enfin le projet de loi
de finance pour 2023 s'inscrit dans un
contexte de forte inflation notamment
sur l'énergie qui pèse sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et sur le
fonctionnement des entreprises et des
collectivités territoriales nous savons
tous pour protéger nos concitoyens les
petites entreprises et les collectivités
subissant une insupportable leur facture
de gaz et d'électricité le bouclier
tarifaire sera prolongé pour l'année
2023 limitant la hausse à 15% pour les
entreprises qui ne seraient pas
éligibles au bouclier tarifaires
l'amortisseur électricité et un guichet
d'aide permettront d'apporter un soutien
nécessaire même si nous sommes
conscients qu'il faudra sans doute aller
plus loin je veux revenir d'un mot sur
l'accompagnement réservé aux
collectivités locales car j'ai entendu
beaucoup de choses faut 10 à 7 tribune
pour les collectivités à un filet de
soutien sera également mis en place à
l'initiative d'ailleurs de notre groupe
et dans des conditions simplifiées par
horizon au dispositif de cette de cet
été avec l'ensemble des députés du
groupe Henri du groupe horizon et
apparenté nous avons voulu mettre en
place un dispositif de soutien
d'investissement des collectivités qui
comptent en le regard de près marche
très bien pour que celui et pour que
celui-ci ne soit pas grévé par la hausse
écoule l'énergie le dispositif ciblé
vise à apporter la meilleure
compensation possible en prenant en
compte l'augmentation des dépenses
d'énergie mais également l'augmentation
des recettes réelles de fonctionnement
le Sénat a d'ailleurs acté le principe
de ce filet de soutien tout en
assouplissant les critères d'accès je
tiens d'ailleurs à remercier les
sénateurs pour leur travail de qualité
qui nous a permis sur ce point-là au
moins d'aboutir un dispositif complet et
efficient notre groupe se félicite de la
reprise de notre amendement de compromis
dans le texte final qui ajoute les
principaux apports du Sénat tout en
concernant qui ajoute aux principaux
apports pardon du Sénat des critères
d'accès pour que le dispositif soit
beaucoup mieux ciblé et effectivement
respectent l'esprit originel au travers
de ce filet de soutien aux collectivités
territoriales mais également de
plusieurs autres amendements sur la
déduction pour épargne de précaution sur
le renforcement du soutien à la filière
bio sur le report de deux ans de la
révision des valeurs locatives des
locaux professionnels sur la meilleure
définition des zones tendues sur les
crédits supplémentaires pour permettre
la revalorisation des aesh à la rentrée
2023 pour maintenir les capacités
d'hébergement d'urgence ou encore pour
accentuer le déploiement des téléphones
graves danger pour les victimes de
violence conjugales les députés du
groupe horizon et apparentés ce sont
pleinement mobilisés tout au long du
débat parlementaire au côté du
gouvernement dans un débat itératif pour
enrichir ce texte nous voterons
évidemment pas cette notion de censure
nous nous tenons aux côtés du
gouvernement conscient des défis man ce
qui nous reste à relever pour réformer
le pays permettre à chacun de vivre de
son travail protéger les plus modestes
et accompagner la transition de notre
système productif vers les révolutions
du 21e siècle je formule le veut au nom
de mon groupe parlementaire que nous
serons retrouvés en 2023 dans un état
d'esprit apaisé propice au débat de
qualité la possibilité de mener à bien
des projets utiles pour la France il en
va de l'avenir de notre pays et de nos
enfants je vous souhaite aussi à tous de
joyeuses fêtes de fin d'année et dans un
dernier élan consensuel allez les bleus
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Cyrielle châtelain pour le groupe
écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je veux
qu'ensemble nous redonnions un sens et
une vertu nous compromis ce sont vos
mots madame la Première ministre
prononcer ici même le 6 juillet dernier
par 10 fois vous avez échoué à suivre la
ligne de conduite que vous vous étiez
fixé par 10 fois vous avez privilégié la
brutalité au dialogue par 10 fois vous
avez esquivé les débats cette notion de
censure ce sont 10 minutes arrachées
contre le verrouillage de nos
institutions 10 minutes pour vous
présenter cette mesure emblématique de
toutes les pistes de travail et de
compromis élaborés par le groupe
écologiste nupes 10 minutes pour vous
rappeler ce dont vous avez par
acharnement privé la France et les
Français 10 minutes pour vous démontrer
pour vous démontrer au français et aux
Français est-ce que l'État aurait pu
avoir un autre budget madame la Première
ministre votre acharnement a priver la
France d'une révolution ferroviaire
depuis les lignes à grande vitesse la
France du rail par exemple si on prend
le lion-grenoble aux heures de pointe
c'est un calvaire pour les passagers
entassés par manque de place victime de
retard trop fréquents et de rame-trope
au nombreuses Christine Arrighi rapporte
spécial sur les infrastructures et
services de transport la Clermont exposé
sans entretien des voies ferrées
suffisantes il n'est pas possible de
faire rouler des trains vous avez rayé
d'entrée de plumes les trois milliards
de vos investissements en faveur du rail
le rail ça modernisation sont
développement ne sont clairement pas vos
priorités budgétaires et pour faire les
10 RER métropolitain tant attendus il va
enfin vous falloir mettre l'argent sur
la table
madame la Première ministre votre
acharnement a priver la France d'une
politique qui privilégie clairement les
transports en commun le Sénat avait
adopté une proposition sur proposition
de nos collègues écologistes un
amendement permettant de baisser la TVA
à 5,5 sur les transports collectifs
cette mesure vous aurez permis
d'appliquer une des nombreuses
préconisations la convention citoyenne
sur le climat que vous avez des décès
parce que plutôt que de livrer la France
au cabinet de conseil que vous payez des
centaines de millions d'euros pour vous
conforter dans votre politique libérale
productiviste et inégalitaire vous
pourriez vous reposer sur les
propositions des citoyens et scènes des
parlementaires cette baisse de la TVA à
5,5 sur les transports collectifs elle
était pertinente en 2021 lorsque la
convention citoyenne pour le climat l'a
fait elle est aujourd'hui indispensable
madame la Première ministre votre
acharnement a priver la France d'un
véritable bouclier tarifaire écologique
l'actuel bouclier tarifaire et
socialement injuste et écologiquement
irresponsable le choc énergétique touche
plus fortement les ménages à faible
revenu en raison du poids plus important
des dépenses d'énergie dans leur budget
or beaucoup d'experts et d'ONG le Réseau
Action Climat l'Institut des politiques
publiques le C primap monte avec le
bouclier tarifaire actuel les ménages
les plus riches touchent plus d'argent
que les plus pauvres deux fois plus les
foyers qui chauffent leur piscine en
hiver touche plus ceux qui ont du mal à
chauffer l'horlogements ce n'est pas
acceptable c'est pour cela que Nicolas
Thierry notre collègue a proposé un
bouclier tarifaire écologique instaurant
une tarification progressive permettant
massivement de soutenir les besoins
essentiels et d'arrêter de subventionner
les comportements superflus
madame la Première ministre votre
acharnement a priver la France d'un
puissant levier pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique 7 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour la
rénovation thermique des logements 7
milliards d'euros pour enfin éradiquer
les passoires thermiques 7 milliards
votés par l'Assemblée nationale grâce à
notre collègue et Vassas ces milliards
vous les avez fait disparaître peut-être
que plus plus de 5 millions de passoires
thermiques c'est visiblement un détail
pour vous mais en fait pour les 12
millions de Français qui souffrent de
précarité énergétique c'est votre
incurie et c'est l'État qui les
abandonne ainsi l'objectif de 15000
passoire énergétiques par an cela vous
semble peut-être beaucoup mais pour tous
les militants associatifs allant de se
engager de longue date comme le Secours
catholique ou la Fondation Abbé Pierre
au plus jeune comme dernière rénovation
c'est peu bien trop peu à ce rythme là
les dernières passoires thermiques
seront traitées en 2352
2352 d'ici là les températures se seront
et c'est encore les plus modestes et les
plus jeunes qui subiront les
conséquences les plus dures madame la
Première ministre votre acharnement a
privé la France de moyens
supplémentaires pour les cantines
scolaires pourtant croyez-moi il est
impossible d'apprendre le ventre vide
fatale explosion des prix les
collectivités locales se battent pour
garder ouvert les services publics de
proximité vous leur avez proposé un
mince filet de sécurité pour faire face
à la hausse des prix d'énergie ce filet
mais justement je vais vous le dire ce
filet de sécurité il est jugé
insuffisant par bon pour par beaucoup de
mères que je rencontre qui n'est
clairement à une opérant nous nous
proposions nous proposions excusez-moi
nous proposions de composer de compenser
cette hausse nous proposons de composer
cette hausse du prix de l'énergie et
nous savions mais nous savions très bien
que vous n'accepteriez pas cette
compensation des hautes des primes
d'énergie pour les collectivités locales
c'est pourquoi dans un esprit de
compromis dans un esprit de compromis
notre collègue Francesca Passini vous
propos de soutenir les écoles et les
collecter et les cantines scolaires de
la hausse du prix de l'énergie les
cantines scolaires parce qu'aujourd'hui
bien manger devient un luxe mais si je
vous invite à venir avec moi j'étais sur
le campus de Grenoble 250 étudiants 250
étudiants qui font la queue qui font la
queue pour pouvoir manger je vous invite
de venir au secours populaire à
Saint-Martin-d'Hères ou c'est les
retraités qui viennent chercher des
colis alimentaires et à Échirolles un
panier solidaire où ce sont les familles
qui viennent aujourd'hui chercher
l'essentiel parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à
se nourrir et donc oui aider les
collectivités à pouvoir faire face à
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie
soutenir les cantines scolaires et ben
oui c'est en fait soutenir toutes ces
familles qui galèrent à manger trois
fois par jour
madame la Première ministre votre
acharnement a prié la France de l'argent
dont elle a tant besoin notre école
tient grâce à la ténacité des équipes
éducatives notre système judiciaire
épuise celles et ceux qui essayent de le
faire tenir notre hôpital s'effondre les
investissements en faveur de la
transition énergétique sont ridiculement
bas les services publics disparaissent
des campagnes et s'éloigne des habitants
malgré cette situation catastrophique
votre choix a été de continuer d'offrir
des milliards d'euros grandes
entreprises ces milliards offerts aux
entreprises c'est l'argent qui manque à
nos services publics
mesdames la première ministre votre
acharnement également privé la France
d'un peu de justice la suppression de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune n'a
bénéficié qu'aux plus riche cette
suppression est le symbole d'une
politique inégalitaire qui demande
beaucoup à ceux qui ont peu et bien peu
à ceux qui ont beaucoup notre
proposition elle est simple restaurer
l'ISF et comme nous sommes en 2022 que
notre combat pour le réchauffement
climatique doit irriguer l'ensemble de
nos politiques mettez une composante
climatique à cette ISSF oui et ça c'est
justifié parce qu'en vrai Bernard
Arnault avec son jet privé pollue bien
plus par exemple que la R5 de mon
grand-père et ce qui est isolant c'est
de pouvoir vous en convaincre
mais je ne sais pas dans quel monde vous
vivez madame la Première ministre on
s'en prend à rêver sur les bancs de la
nupes que pour cette nuit des années
vous mettiez en cohérence vos propos qui
prônent le compromis et vos actes c'est
pourquoi je vous propose une résolution
une seule bonne résolution vous
Elisabeth borne vous engageriez à ne
plus escamoter la démocratie et pour
cette nouvelle année 2023 je veux aussi
assurer les Français et les Françaises
que sur les bancs de la nups nous
abordons cette année avec plus d'ardeurs
avec plus d'engagement et cela dès le
mois de janvier pour mettre en échec
votre réforme des retraites à 65 ans et
je leur dis aux Français et aux
Françaises la Maison du peuple sera au
rendez-vous du combat social
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît mes
chers collègues un petit lance
s'il vous plaît
il y a de l'ambiance
[Musique]
bon s'il vous plaît mes chers collègues
est-ce que vous pouvez faire silence
pour qu'on écoute le dernier orateur
allez-y monsieur Dupont-Aignan merci
madame la Première ministre mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons dans
cette hémicique pour un énième débat de
censure mais madame la Première ministre
émotion ne tombe pas du ciel c'est bien
parce que vous piétinez la
représentation nationale avec un dixième
49,3 que nous débattons aujourd'hui de
cette nouvelle motion alors les faits
sont là et les Français le savent de
plus en plus en nous regardant avec
Emmanuel Macron vous méprisez
profondément les représentants de la
nation car vous ne supportez pas et vous
n'avez jamais supporté depuis mois de
juin d'être minoritaire dans cette
hémicycle c'est le constat avec Emmanuel
Macron vous faites souffrir comme jamais
le peuple français car vous êtes
incapable de prendre les bonnes
décisions qui s'imposent pour résoudre
enfin les graves problèmes de notre pays
avec Emmanuel Macron vous n'arrivez pas
à prendre ces décisions car vous
obéissez et c'est là le cœur du problème
à une union européenne oligarchique et
corrompu on le sait maintenant qui joue
ouvertement contre notre intérêt
national quelques exemples vous êtes
incapable de relocaliser nos emplois
malgré vos discours avec un déficit
commercial abyssal car vous acceptez la
naïveté effarante de la Commission de
Bruxelles qui continue de signer des
accords de libre-échange quand la Chine
est maintenant les États-Unis s'exonère
de toutes les règles de l'OMC vous êtes
incapable d'empêcher la submersion
migratoire ce terme est d'ailleurs de
Gérard Collomb car vous acceptez la
politique de suppression des frontières
intérieures et d'appel d'air de l'Union
européenne mais l'exemple le plus
frappant le plus révoltant de cette
incroyable servitude volontaire
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'égard des intérêts
étrangers et celui de la fixation du
prix de l'électricité en France un vrai
scandale d’état et je veux parler et
consacrer les quelques minutes que j'ai
à ces dizaines de milliers d'artisans
qui sont en train de mourir comment la
France qui produit l'électricité la
moins chère d'Europe peut laisser mourir
oui ces entreprises c'est commerce ces
artisans ces boulangers ces bouchers
comment peut-elle accepter avec un prix
de marché européen exorbitant et
artificiel indexés sur le gaz ce n'est
pas moi qui le dis c'est le site
comparatif de prix de l'électricité de
l'Union européenne le 14 décembre vous
pouvez regarder le prix du
mégawatt-heure était de 451 euros en
France alors qu'il était seulement de 81
euros mes chers collègues en Espagne au
Portugal aujourd'hui le différentiel est
de 133 euros en faveur de ces deux pays
la raison de cet écart est simple
l'Espagne et le Portugal ont eu le
courage de revenir à un prix nationale
de l'électricité fondée sur les coûts
réels de production ce qui ne les
empêche en rien contrairement à ce que
vous dites de rester interconnecté avec
leurs voisins pourquoi vous entêtez vous
à refuser cette décision de bon sens
pour obéir à l'Allemagne à l'Union
européenne pour servir des profiteurs
privés il est honteux de ne pas revenir
à un prix national de l'électricité
quand on sait que vous obligez EDF à
vendre la sienne à 46 euros le
mégawatt-heure à des opérateurs privés
qui raquettent nos entreprises à des
prix 10 à 20 fois supérieur grâce à cela
ces opérateurs qui n'ont pas fait
l'effort d'investir à long terme comme
EDF dans nos centrales nucléaires font
des bénéfices extravagants jusqu'à 180
euros le mégawattheure et vous vous
prenez ce qui est au-dessus pour remplir
les caisses de l'État pour être
parfaitement clair votre gouvernement
qui se refuse toujours à instaurer un
bouclier tarifaire pour nos PME nos
Artis mais une simple aide partielle sur
25% du différentiel de prix contribue
aujourd'hui à leur faillite et pendant
ce temps-là mes chers collègues le
gouvernement allemand prend en charge
les factures du mois de décembre de tous
les ménages et annonce qu'au 1er janvier
toutes les entreprises ne paieront pas
un centime de plus que 130 euros le
mégawattheure pour elle on marche sur la
tête c'est du sabotage organisé c'est du
sabotage de nos forces économiques
organisées comment pouvez-vous accepter
cela alors il est temps de reprendre la
maîtrise de notre destin il est temps de
défendre notre intérêt national comme le
font d'ailleurs les autres pays
l'Espagne le Portugal l'Allemagne et
c'est pour cela qu'ils obtiennent des
résultats et c'est pour cela qu'ils ont
peut-être la confiance de leurs
concitoyens seul le vote d'une motion de
censure bloquerait Emmanuel Macron dans
sa déconstruction de la France seul le
vote d'une motion de censure
l'obligerait à changer de cap ou mieux
encore à dissoudre pour demander au
peuple français d'arbitré ce conflit de
légitimité entre lui et cet assemblée le
plus tôt serait le mieux car chaque mois
qui passe de ces jeux politiciens
dérisoirs des gouttes un peu plus les
Français et accélère la tiers
mondialisation de notre pays mes chers
collègues il serait urgent de censurer
ce gouvernement
merci la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
alors quand cette fin de semaine nous
touchons au terme du délai
constitutionnel pour l'examen de ce
projet de loi de finance le moment doit
nous pousser je crois à un bilan
mais avant de dresser ce bilan je
voudrais vous dire à quel point j'ai été
choqué par le ton de certains orateurs
en particulier le député Guiraud
je ne sais pas si c'est très molo dans
la voix sont surjoués ou s'ils croient
vraiment ce qu'il dit
peu ma porte au fond mais je voudrais
vous dire quelque chose
croyez-vous vraiment que vous êtes ici
les seules représentants de la nation
croyez-vous que vous êtes les seuls à
vous confronter à la détresse de nos
concitoyens c'est insupportable monsieur
le député quand on croit être les seuls
à détenir la vérité quand on déni aux
autres le droit de penser autrement
c'est toujours le prélude à des périodes
sombres alors Monsieur le Député avant
de rejoindre cette hémicycle je
travaillais avec le ministre délégué au
logement Monsieur Olivier Klein au
renforcement de nos dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence je lui demandais
d'accélérer la mobilisation de tous les
moyens de l'État c'était à ça mesdames
et messieurs les députés que mon
gouvernement travaille et permettez-moi
de vous le dire j'ai trouvé comme
souvent mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la France insoumise vos
postures
et tellement s'il vous plaît quel en
deviennent indignes
[Applaudissements]
on travaille démissionné alors Monsieur
Corbière s'il vous plaît
non mais arrêtez d'interrompre sans
cesse l'orateur
alors rien que sur ce texte si motion de
censure ont été déposées et nous avons
passé plus de 25 heures à les examiner
plutôt que de débattre du texte
au total sur le projet de loi de
finances
au total sur le projet de loi de finance
et le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire seulement
sur deux textes 12 notions de censure
auront été déposées rabotant sans cesse
le temps des débats
les historiens les historiens qui les
historiens qui regarderont cette période
se demanderont sans doute ce que pouvait
contenir ces deux projets de loi pour
qu'ils suscitent un tel acharnement à
vouloir faire tomber le gouvernement
pour que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour que sur une période
pour que sur une période de quelques
semaines
bon attendez madame la Première ministre
écoutez vous avez tous eu votre temps de
parole nous vous avons tous écouté donc
maintenant c'est à madame la Première
ministre de réponse et c'est ainsi que
se passe les débats sur une motion de
censure si vous ne souhaitez pas que ça
se déroule ainsi vous pouvez soit
quitter l'hémicycle soit ne pas déposer
de motion madame la Première ministre
vous avez la parole
pour que sur une période de quelques
semaines
pour que
pour que sur une période de quelques
semaines sur seulement deux textes je le
rappelle plus de motion de censure était
déposées que sous Michel Rocard Edith
Cresson et Pierre Bérégovoy réunis très
vite ils pourront écarter une première
hypothèse la faute aux 49-3 de 1988 à
1993 huit motions de censure avait été
déposée huit motions de censure avaient
été déposée pour 39 recours à l'article
49.3
il ne s'agit donc en aucun cas d'une
tradition parlementaire et encore moins
d'un moyen de montrer son appartenance à
l'opposition le degré d'opposition ne
s'est jamais mesuré au nombre de motions
de censure
par ailleurs
par ailleurs l'argument de la motion de
censure comme rempart un prétendu
passage en force ne tient pas un instant
il serait insensé de parler de passage
en force dans une assemblée où le
gouvernement ne dispose pas de la
majorité absolue et s'expose donc à être
renversé et s'expose donc à être
renversé si une majorité alternative
devait exister
enfin l'argument insoumis de la motion
de censure en défense de la Cinquième
République ne tient pas plus il est
d'ailleurs cocasse que ceux qui ont fait
campagne pour la Sixième République se
proclame aujourd'hui les plus ardents
défenseurs de la 5e
[Applaudissements]
alors sans doute les historiens se
pencheront-ils sur le contenu de nos
débats
il est grand que ce projet de loi de
finance par trois fois a été adoptée
dans son ensemble par la commission des
finances de cette assemblée ils verront
que le gouvernement a laissé les débats
se tenir le plus longtemps possible lors
de la première lecture de ce texte
et il constateront comme nous que nous
étions contraints par les délais
constitutionnels lors de la nouvelle
lecture je rappelle que ces délais sont
terminés aujourd'hui même
et pour percer le mystère de ses motions
de censure à répétition les historiens
regarderont sans doute le compte rendu
intégral de nos débats
alors pendant l'examen de ces notions de
censure de quoi avons-nous parler
de l'Union parfois et de la désignation
souvent de la nupesse sur la marche à
tenir pendant ces débats d'alliance de
circonstances contre nature mais
récurrente entre le rassemblement
national et la France insoumise pour
tenter de faire tomber le gouvernement
les historiens verront aussi les oracles
du Cher leader de la France insoumise
qui a défaut d’être sur ses bancs
commenté depuis son blog le cours des
choses un jurrier ces alliés de la
nupesse et donnaient la recette de la
bonne motion de censure celle qui peut
être votée d'une extrême à l'autre de
cette assemblée
[Musique]
Guiraud votre leçon de démocratie nous a
émue on comprend que vous évoquez un
monde dont vous rêvez pour vous-même un
monde où la démocratie pourra franchir
les portes de la France insoumise nous
l'espérons tous pour vous ce jour ou vos
mots et vos actes seront peut-être en
accord
[Applaudissements]
j'ajoute que si certains chercheurs
décident de ne pas s'arrêter au texte
mais de regarder la vidéo de nos
échanges il constateront il constateront
que bien souvent les hurlements du
groupe censeurs couvraient la voie de
ceux qui prenaient la parole
et que ceux qui prétendent être les
défenseurs de la démocratie
défenseurs de la démocratie sont
décidément ceux qui supportent le moins
le choix des urnes les opinions
contraires et d'être mis face à leur
contradiction
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
permettez-moi d'éclairer ceux qui se
pencheront sur cette période
[Musique]
si la si la France insoumise si la
France insoumise a considérablement
réduit le temps du débat si la France
insoumise à temps voulu qu'on parle de
méthode et surtout pas du fond du texte
c'est sans doute pour masquer une
certaine gêne une gêne car ce texte
répond aux aspirations des Français aux
besoins des plus précaires aux attentes
des collectivités et des entreprises au
soutien à nos services publics
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise vous avez préféré les
censures à répétition comme un écran de
fumée pour masquer tous les progrès
sociaux auxquels vous vous êtes opposé
et je comprends vos embarras
car quand on prétend défendre les
enseignants comment leur expliquer que
vous rejetiez une hausse de 10 voire 20%
de leur salaire c'est ça la baisse du
budget de l'Éducation nationale monsieur
le Président Valo quand on prétend l'un
quand on prétend défendre l'inclusion
des personnes en situation de handicap
comment expliquer que vous vouliez
censurer une revalorisation de 10% des
aesh
quand on prétend être à l'avant-garde de
la transition écologique comment
expliquer que vous refusiez un fond vert
de 2 milliards d'euros pour les
collectivités
j'avoue madame la Présidente Chatelain
que votre aveuglement est stupéfiant
évolue sont anxieuses et au fond
méprisantes ne paraissent totalement
déplacés le réel vous agace car il ne
correspond pas à vos schémas entre les
bons et les méchants il y a ceux qui
agissent je serai toujours de ce côté là
et mesdames et messieurs les députés de
la de la nupes quand on prétend défendre
les magistrats comment comment expliquer
que vous refusiez une hausse de 8% soit
25% en 3 ans du budget de la justice
quand on prétend se battre pour
l'égalité famome comment justifier de
refuser une nouvelle hausse des crédits
qui sont consacrés des crédits des
crédits qui ont doublé par rapport à
2017 et surtout quand on prétend
défendre les plus modestes quand on
revendique avec constance d'être les
seuls légitimes à parler au nom du
peuple comment pourriez-vous dire à nos
concitoyens que vous refusez le bouclier
tarifaire ce bouclier qui limite à 15%
la hausse du gaz et de l'électricité
pour tous les ménages et sa compagne
d'un chèque d'un chèque énergie
exceptionnel pour les 40% de ménage les
plus fragiles comment pourriez-vous dire
aux travailleurs modestes que vous ne
voulez pas de la prime de 100 euros face
à la hausse des prix des carburants
comme on pourriez-vous dire au
collectivité et aux entreprises que vous
préférez que leur facture d'énergie
explosent
et Monsieur le Député Nicolas sangsue ce
projet de loi de finances ce ne sont pas
des mots d'émotion ce sont des actes
concrets pour nous concitoyens pour nos
entreprises pour nos collectivités
alors oui alors oui puisque vous vous
opposez avec tant de véhémence et de
constance aux progrès social puisque
vous tournez le dos à des avancées que
vous promettez à vos électeurs oui je
préfère je comprends que vous préfériez
débattre de vos émotions de censure
plutôt que du projet de loi de finances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors mesdames et messieurs les députés
de la France insoumise au final que
retiendront les historiens ils verront
qu'à 10 reprises vous avez tenté de
faire tomber le gouvernement qu'a dit
reprises vous avez échoué et qu'à dire
reprises vous avez fait l'éclatante
démonstration de ce que nous savions
tous vous n'avez pas la majorité
confirmation s'il en était besoin de ce
qu'on décider les électeurs au prétend
au printemps 2022 je sais que vous avez
du mal à vous y résoudre mais ne vous en
déplaise les Françaises et les Français
ont élu Emmanuel Macron président de la
République et mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la nuit pêche vous êtes
minoritaire
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
arrivons au terme de l'examen des textes
financiers je regrette que nous n'ayons
pas su collectivement trouver les voies
et moyens d'un compromis au service de
nos concitoyens alors non monsieur le
Président Vallot je ne satisfais pas de
cette situation mais vous aurez beau le
répéter mille fois non nous n'avons pas
foulé au pied ni la démocratie ni la
représentation nationale nous avons mis
en œuvre nous avons mis en œuvre ce qui
est notre responsabilité première donnée
un budget à la France
il y avait pourtant un chemin entre le
soutien au gouvernement et la motion de
censure systématique mais je suis lucide
les élections sont encore proches
c'était la première fois que nous
examinions le budget avec cette
configuration dans notre Assemblée
nationale notre méthode se construit
elle avance nous devrons tirer les
enseignements de cette période et chacun
devrait le faire j'ai parfois le
sentiment mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la de la nupes que le confort
de la critique vous exempte facilement
de toute démarche d'autocritique nous
devrons donc toutes et tous gouvernement
majorité et opposition trouver les
moyens de dialoguer plus de dialoguer
mieux de débattre plus longtemps des
textes et pourquoi pas d'arriver à
construire un budget ensemble pour
l'heure l'urgence est au pouvoir d'achat
au combat pour le plein emploi à la
transition écologique à la lutte pour
l'égalité des chances et la protection
de nous souveraineté la a besoin d'un
budget et avec mon gouvernement nous
avons pris nos responsabilités je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre
donc la discussion est close je vais
maintenant mettre au voile à la motion
de censure le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'ensemble des national je
rappelle que seuls les députés
favorables à la motion de censure
participe au scrutin que le vote se
déroule dans les salles voisines de
l'hémicycle le scrutin est ouvert pour
30 minutes il sera clos à 18h la séance
est suspendue
alors la séance est reprise voici le
résultat du scrutin majorité requise
pour l'adoption de la motion de censure
sur la majorité absolue des membres
composant l'assemblée 288 pour
l'adoption 101 donc la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée en conséquence
le projet de loi de finance pour 2023
est considéré comme adopté en lecture
définitive
prochaine séance lundi 9 janvier à 16h
la séance est levée bonne fête de fin
d'année à tous